that's very cool three-two-one
yeah a guy named was online Twitter
errors Instagram handles TGT studios and
he makes these I actually had one made
for Elon Elon Musk loved it too so we
made him one with he made one with like
this very beautiful redwood and those
are what are those things made out of
Jamie that some diodes or something
Nixie tubes
Nixie tubes yes yeah he has to get them
from Russia that's uh he has them
delivered over from Russia so they might
have like listening devices implanted in
them as well yeah so Brian good to see
you man great to be back yeah great to
have you back so tell me what this tour
that you're doing it's a it's a willed
tool try to keep this sucker like a
fistful oh yeah there you go
how's that perfect yeah it's a world
tour starts next week in the UK and then
we go everywhere from the South Island
in New Zealand all the way to the Arctic
Circle so Svalbard which is north the
furthest north that you can go on a
commercial aircraft in the middle of
we're in the States for a month in a
mainly May and yeah it's it's about
cosmology and about the questions that
cosmology raises so if you're interested
in the science of how did the universe
begin even questions of what may have
been there is the universe eternal is
there such a thing as before the Big
Bang what is the future of the universe
how does complexity emerge spontaneously
in a universe I mean we sort of take you
for granted that we there's a big bang
and it's all hot and there's just this
kind of hot glow of stuff and I out said
that spontaneously in 13.8 billion years
you get something like the earth with
the civilization and life on it so how
does that do we know anything about that
I mean we do I'm asking the question
atomically we know quite a lot about it
so it's it's really about showing the
size and scale of the universe but
addressing those questions I think
everybody has about what is it what does
it mean to be human this tiny little
finite life that we lead in a possibly
infinite universe
sense of that well it's incredibly
exciting to me that there's a giant
audience for this and that what Neil
deGrasse Tyson had been doing and what a
lot of public touring intellectuals are
doing now they're doing these giant
theaters and these people are coming out
to see these shows and we're realizing
that there's I'm I hate to use the term
market for this but there's a demand for
this and there's a lot of people who are
incredibly fascinated by this and yeah
it's it's spreading information
expressing knowledge yeah I mean in the
UK particularly I mean do Wembley Arena
for example you're talking about 10,000
people 12 times equal and you're right
they are coming all the other you know
their big shows spectacular screens and
all that they're coming for to think
that they're coming to hear about what
we know about the universe and nature
and I think you know I think I'm not
surprised people are interested because
these are questions everybody asks you
know I mean just why am I here you know
everybody's asking that question but I
my point is that there is a framework
there's a framework of knowledge there
are things we know about the universe so
it is true that science scientists are
not going to tell you why you're here
they're not gonna tell you what the
meaning of life is but there is actually
a there are things you need to know if
you want to start to explore those
questions for yourself
but you need to know that there are two
trillion galaxies in the observable
universe you need to know that the Milky
Way galaxy has got 200 billion stars
most of those stars now we know have
planetary systems we estimate there are
something like 20 billion earth-like
planets or potentially earth-like
planets in the Milky Way galaxy alone so
if you're asking questions about what is
my place in the universe you need to
know those things first of all it's a
framework within which you can think
when you get to those numbers when
you're talking about trillions and
billions and though all those zeros my
brain just goes numb there's this lack
of comprehension that I'm well aware of
like those numbers get thrown about I go
oh 200 billion hmm I think everybody
does I think I've every scientist and no
scientist can picture that number I mean
he even the small number 200 billion
starts in one galaxy and then when you
say two trillion galaxies you know
that's I challenge anyone to be able to
picture that but it is the reality that
we've observed we've you know we haven't
counted all to trillion by the way we
have you ever think all the Sloan
Digital Sky Survey which maps the
positions of galaxies so you can you
know how much of the sky you've surveyed
and you know how many galaxies you
counted and then you can spread that
across the wider universe and you get
this picture of a vast and possibly
infinite universe I mean we we know that
the universe are very strongly suspect
at the university is much bigger than
the piece we can see so we have good
reason to think that's the case
whether it's infinite or not is another
question and then that goes to your you
know that can you picture infinity well
no one can picture infinity you know we
say the universe began 13.8 billion
years ago so that's a measurement so
because we can measure the speed that
all the galaxies are flying away from us
essentially and then you so you can run
time backwards if you like so to find
out when they were all on top of each
other and so quite simple measurement
and we've done that so we say the
universe began 13.8 billion years ago
but actually all we know really was the
universe was very hot and very dense at
that time and we have some theories that
the universe was in existence before
that and perhaps some sort of
circumstantial evidence and that means
that actually the universe could could
have always been there eternal and then
when I talk to people sometimes they get
a bit some people get upset about that
some people would rather it had a
beginning the idea that it might have
been around forever is more frightening
somehow than the fact that it began now
it's it's interesting the way that
people's minds work what what terrifies
you the most an eternal universe or a
finite universe yeah they're both
incomprehensible though the eternal
universe the if there was an eternal
universe is that negate the theory of
the Big Bang or does it mean that
there's a constant cycle of big bangs
and then expansion and then
recompression or it could do so those
theories are back
King vogue some of those theories are
back in vogue again so yes some of them
say that there's a cycling universe so
the Big Bang is an event when space gets
very hot and very dense and filled with
particles and that may happen again are
some of the other theories there's a
theory called eternal inflation which is
a theory there and it's actually the
most popular theory I think at the
moment but what happened but why the Big
Bang is the way that it is who's got
some very special features the Big Bang
which we could talk about but inflation
is the idea that space space-time was
around before the Big Bang and it was
expanding extremely fast there was
doubling in size in the most popular of
these theories every 10 to the minus 37
seconds which is point no no no no 37
knots one of a second so he's an
unimaginably fast expansion and then the
idea is that draws to a close so quite
naturally so dies away in the expansion
slows down and all the energy that was
taken there was causing that expansions
sort of gets dumped into space and heats
it up and makes particles and that's
what we call the Big Bang and those
theories that slight extension to those
say that that slowing down just happens
in little patches so most of the
universe the overwhelming majority the
universe is still inflating that insane
speed and that just little patchy stop
and there Big Bang's so you get multiple
universes a multiverse it's called the
inflationary multiverse and we are in
one of those bubbles and that's what
have the more popular theories that's
another one I mean but right now I'm
aware of what you're saying I can I can
sort of visualize it in some sort of a
graphic form but it's incomprehensible
like my mind doesn't it doesn't have the
capacity to expand the this sense of
distance and size to that that grasp is
this because of just the way we evolved
we evolved here on earth to deal with
the space that's in front of us and now
over the course of you know in
industrial civilization and education
we're now grasping these concepts that
are so alien to the reality that
the tangible reality that we exist in
everyday I'm sure that's right and
they're the you know even very simple
things like you go back to the Greeks so
Aristotle and there's great you know
very clever people but they thought the
earth was a center of the universe no
why because it feels like it's at the
same time it feels like we're not moving
and that's quite a deep point actually
in physics it's like why is it that
we're flying around relative to the Sun
very fast at whatever speed is 80 miles
a second or something like that and the
whole solar system is going around the
Milky Way galaxy and so on why is it
that we don't feel it and then the
Greeks quite naturally said well because
we're at the center of the universe
they also said everything falls towards
the earth so therefore the earth
possibly at the center is its natural
right and actually it's quite a deep
thought so to understand why it didn't
feel that we're moving you you have to
go all the way to Einstein really for
someone to take that very seriously and
he said actually he said well this
there's a great little explanation in
Stephen Hawking's brief history of time
about this that the idea that you can't
tell whether you're moving or not
demolish is the notion of absolute space
so if we think about spective as its
face of you or most people I suppose
you'd think the way that Newton did have
a big box within which things happen and
that's gotta be that's a natural picture
of space and the universe isn't it a
thing in which all the planets and
galaxies are placed but in in the brief
history of time Hawking says well
imagine bouncing a ball so he bounced a
ball that stable now a tennis ball so I
drop it and I catch you again so let's
say I drop it it takes a second to
bounce up so in that second the earth
has moved about 80 miles or so in space
around the Sun so you could ask the
question did that ball return to the
same place in space or not and the
answer is you can't answer it it does
from our perspective but from the
perspective is someone watching the
earth go all the way around the Sun it
when I caught it again it had moved 80
miles and then from some other
perspective it would have done something
else so the point is you can't say this
is a point in space it came back to the
same place because
that just depends on your perspective
depends on whether you watching the Sun
the earth go around the Sun on whatever
it is so so Einstein said that means
there's no such thing as absolute space
which kind of follows if you think about
it but that's a difficult it's it's a
cool but difficult thought process right
I mean that's that's essentially what's
happening when you're on a plane I mean
if you're throwing a ball up in the air
and catching it on the plane it's
happening in a much smaller scale right
yeah yeah I mean you're flying it
whatever six hundred miles an hour
relative to the ground but when you're
sitting there yeah and Einstein elevated
that to a principle and said if you're
moving it a beauty you're not
accelerating you're just moving at a
constant speed in a plane or now I mean
that's essentially what we're doing now
we're moving around the Sun it
effectively constant speed then you
can't tell so there's no experiment you
can do we could look at the decay of a
radioactive nucleus or some electricity
and magnetism or bounce a ball have a
pendulum whatever it is and there's no
experiment you can do to tell you
whether you're moving or not therefore
that concept has no meaning because you
can't measure it and that that's led
Einstein to relativity so that that's
the basis of general relativity which is
our best theory of the universe now why
is it that we think that the known
universe is larger than we can observe
well one point is that it's an expanding
and and we always see the same radiation
out there so the glow of the Big Bang
but there's some deeper reasons and the
one from the theory of inflation there
the the best way to explain the universe
the properties that we see is that it's
very much bigger than the piece we can
see so for example we measure space to
be what's called flat I don't mean I'd
say what's called flat it is flat so if
you imagine slices of space let's
imagine slices of them at different
times so you just slice the universe and
say there's a big sheets like this today
I could tear a sheet of space and
there's another sheet another sheet and
it can it can have a geometry right
flat like a tabletop or it could be
curved like a sphere or it could be
curved in the opposite direction sort of
like a saddle or a bowl and we can
measure that and when we measure it we
see its absolutely flat and that's a
very unusual thing for it to be like it
requires because what Einstein's theory
says is that the shape of space that the
curvature of space is determined by the
stuff that's in it that's that's
basically Einstein's theory of general
relativity put stuff in space and it
curbs it and bends it and warps it and
stretches it and so on and what we find
is that with there's precisely the right
amount of stuff in the universe to have
a completely flat universe and the the
explanation the most favored explanation
for that is the universe is way bigger
than the piece we can see and so it's
like looking at a piece of the earth oh
you look a little one mile square of the
earth right then it's flat I mean you
have to look at big distances it's kind
of a vorded the radius of the earth or
not you know bigger bigger than 1
kilometer anyway on 1 mile to see that
actually you're on a curved surface and
that's one of the ideas about the the
universe and white appears to be the way
that it is because it's way way bigger
so we just we're just looking at a
little piece and that's why it looks
flat and that's one of the ideas
now when you say flat like that my brain
doesn't understand this because from our
perspective when you look up at the
Milky Way you see all these stars all
over the place so if you're saying flat
like it wow much height and what what
are you saying
so terms of like the way to measure it
the best way to think about it is not to
think of three dimensions of space
because then we can't picture it
ok but you can think of two like this
tabletop and that's all right we just
forget the other one for now and so you
know what flat is on this table I mean
you could define it so you could say for
example that if I draw a triangle on the
top of the table then all the angles add
up to 180 degrees so that actually
defines flat if you did that on the
surface of the earth with a big triangle
then the angles wouldn't add up 280
degrees or you could draw a circle and
say what's pi so pi is the ratio of the
circle
inference of a circle to its diameter
that's only true on a flat surface it's
different if the surface is curved so
you can define flatness so when you but
even when you're saying flatness how
what is the height and what is the width
like if you're talking about it as if
it's a table there must be some sort of
a there's a dimension to it correct oh
yeah there's a third dimension of space
but the same applies it's just a
generalization of geometry then say you
can pick there fires we can picture it
in two dimensions but you can you can
draw you can quite literally you could
imagine sending like beams out then we
do this measurement actually we can look
at the the disk the most distant light
we can see which is something called the
cosmic microwave background radiation
which is if you if you imagine looking
out if you look at the Andromeda galaxy
which we can see with the naked eye here
in LA you can see that it's the most
distant object you can see with the
naked eye and it's about 2 2 million
light years away also which means the
light took 2 million years to get to us
so it's a long way away but it's very
big so as you look further out into the
universe 2 more and more distant
galaxies you're looking further back in
time because you look at something
that's a billion light years away then
the light took a billion years to get to
us so you see as it was a billion years
in the past and we can actually look so
far out that we can see almost back to
13.8 billion years ago which is very
close to the Big Bang so we can look to
light that began its journey before
there were galaxies and that's the
oldest light in the universe which is by
the way one of the one of the pieces of
evidence when people say I don't believe
in the Big Bang the answer is where you
can see it so actually just there you
can see it we have pictures of it and
that light it turns out that there are
such structures or ripples in that light
which we can use as a ruler so quite
literally as a ruler on the sky and then
because that light's been traveling
through the universe we can see how that
rule has been distorted as the light is
travelled through space and so we can
infer whether space is flat or curved or
how it's warps if you like just from
that measurement
it's a beautiful measurement is it
possible that in the future we'll be
able to see past 13.8 billion years not
with light no because what the picture
is that before it's actually was
released 380,000 years after the Big
Bang it's a very precise number you
might say how do you know that well
before that time the universe was so hot
the atoms couldn't form so you had a
soup of electrically charged particles
it was just too hot for electrons to go
into orbit around nuclei so the universe
was opaque to light so you just couldn't
it's like one almost like a big glowing
star if you like and then when it was
expanding it cooled past the point where
the atoms could form and at that point
it becomes transparent really almost
instantly in a cosmic timescale and so
the light could then travel in straight
lines through the universe and we can
see that light so we see the light from
that time but further back than there
it's opaque so you can't see past that
with light but you can potentially with
gravitational waves which is this
measurement that got the Nobel Prize a
couple of years ago the LIGO experiment
here in the United States and that see
it looks for ripples in the fabric of
space and time and in principle if we
had a big enough detector you could see
the ripples from the Big Bang so you
couldn't you could take an image of the
Big Bang in gravitational waves which
would be but you need enormous of space
based datang so that we're not going to
build any time soon no obviously this is
all through equipment and technology
that's been invented over the last few
hundred years and perfected is it
possible that things could get better
and you could get some some ability to
detect things even in a far more distant
way yeah I mean the gravitational waves
are incredible I mean Einstein predicted
them in 1915 never thought they'd be
detected because you need to search your
hyper you need lasers for him didn't
have lasers but they think like oh this
experiment which is half in near Seattle
in Washington state and half in
Louisiana so they've got two detectors
and they're basically so ever and no
three-mile-long laser beams and that
just sit and measure this of stretching
and school
king of space as the riffles in the
fabric of the universe and go through
and and what they've been observing
collisions of black holes so you can
imagine how extreme like a colliding
black holes it said incredibly extreme
event so it shakes the fabric of the
universe and the riffles come across the
universe and these laser beams but she
just basically rulers can detect it they
just so ring ganas like you know just
vibrate as the ripples go through in
space and time they keep Thorne he got
the Nobel Prize last year for this he's
one of the greatest living physicists so
I was assigned describe it as a storm in
time so you've got this is a time to
storm it's a beautiful image so that
technology is incredible because it the
change in length is a kind of an exact
number but it's way way way less than
the diameter of an atomic nucleus so the
change in length of the beams it's tiny
measurement but we can do it so this
time a collision of black holes the idea
that you can detect that yeah yeah they
they were I said the paper the first
paper they published their to black
holes and they were about 30 times the
mass of the Sun each and they're
orbiting each other and spiraling in
towards each other and they accelerated
at one point they were approaching each
other at one-third the speed of light
and they accelerated to two-thirds of
speed of light in a tenth of a second
and they'll hit each other and the
explosion the energy release was I think
I'm right it was something like 50 times
the energy release that the power of all
the stars in the observable universe
glowing and it was something like 50
times that amount of energy for a tiny
fraction of a second but it's an
unimaginably violent event and that's
why our detectors can see the ripples
that that makes in space and time and we
detected at least two or three of them
now and also two neutron stars colliding
we saw that as well with it so it's an
incredible machine which is why it got
the Nobel Prize now there's a
supermassive black hole the center of
every
Galaxy yeah there is also other black
holes that aren't necessarily in the
center of galaxies yeah so these little
ones a little they a few times the mass
of the Sun and they're from collapse
tiles so they are stars at the end of
their life very bigger than the Sun more
massive than the Sun but they run out of
their fuel and they start to collapse
because gravity squashes them and if
they're sufficiently massive then
there's nothing that can stop the
collapse and so they collapse as far as
we know to a point right essentially an
infinitely dense point we don't really
know what happens at we don't know what
happens right in the middle but they
collapsed a search and extent that
there's a region around it where from
which light can't escape and that's a so
nothing can escape and that that's a
black hole and what happens to them do
they travel are they moving through
space yeah they're still stars right you
know so they they're still there they're
surrounded this region where have you
fallen it's called the event horizon
and if you go across that horizon then
you are going to the center there's one
way of thinking about it which is quite
cool which is that the time and space
sort of flip is one way to think about
it so in the same way that we are going
into the future now so we're going to
tomorrow there's nothing we can do about
it we are going to tomorrow in the same
way if you fall in across the event
horizon of a black hole you are going to
the middle the singularity is called so
that's that's your future every every
line of your future points to the center
of the black hole so it's kind of the
ultimate I've no escape for the ultimate
prison you're gonna get squashed to an
infinitely dense so anoint not every
star becomes a black hole at the end of
its life no because if something like
the Sun and we have a small star it's
quite small yeah and when it collapses
there's a there's a sort of pressure a
force if you like which is caused by the
fact that electrons don't like to be
very close to each other so it's called
the Pauli exclusion principle
but essentially what happens is that so
as they get squashed closer and closer
together they move faster and faster to
get out of each other's way if you like
and that makes a force which holds them
up and so that creates what's called a
white dwarf star so you can have a blob
of matte so they're about the size of
the earth but they're about the mass of
the Sun and so that's that's for smaller
stars they end up as these white dwarf
things which are very dense objects
there's another version which is called
the neutron star which is the same thing
but for neutrons and they they move
faster and faster so if it's if it's
massive enough that it overwhelms the
electron thing then the electrons sort
crush into protons and turn into
neutrons and the whole thing starts
again and so a neutron star can be you
know elite one-and-a-half times the mass
of the Sun let's say but it can be about
what 10 miles across so so that's an
incredibly dense ball of matter held up
by this the neutrons moving around it's
got a fancy name it's called Neutron
degeneracy pressure but I someone did it
but if you go even bigger then even that
can't hold it up and as far as we know
then there's no known force that we know
of that can hold hold the thing up if
it's too massive and so that's when it
just we almost winks out of existence if
you like oh it collapses and collapses
and collapses and and that's when you
get a black hole we try to put that into
perspective the earth the Sun is a
million times bigger than the earth yeah
and this this neutron star is would you
say one and a half times the mass of
this yes it has miles wide yeah yeah so
and it allowed to those around that they
called pulsars so we see those all over
the place though the first one that was
discovered was called lgm1
because there's spin very fast and then
it was called lgm1
because it's a very regular pulse and
they thought it was little green men so
they called it kind of jokingly little
green men one and then so yeah we've
seen that there's one called the crab
pulsar which is in the Crab Nebula which
we saw the supernova explosion so that's
when one of these stars explodes at the
end of its life and then collapses to
form a neutron star and we saw that in
1054 ad
wasn't there some speculation that our
gal or our solar system at one point was
was a binary star system and that one of
those stars had become a dwarf I don't
know and some someone had read something
about that in relationship to the dense
object they believe is outside the
Kuiper belt yeah I mean there's some
evidence there's a bit of evidence that
there's something out there yeah yeah
good because of the periodic extinctions
and things on earth you get periodic
bombardments from out in the Kuiper belt
so yeah I think one of the theories is
realloc extinctions well yeah so feel
like the you know that they've been
there have been mass extinctions on
earth where a lot of the life died and
then we don't know what caused all those
but sometimes their impacts from space
that seems clear and so yeah there are
theories that there's something orbiting
out there which can disrupt all these
objects out in the Kuiper belt that
sends loads of comets and asteroids
inwards to the inner solar system can
cause havoc so there's some people look
at those theories I mean I don't know
it's one of those it is a possibility
the speculation was that there's
something out there's correct me if I'm
wrong something called the Galactic
Shelf like that it gets to a certain
space in it indicates that there's
something far larger out there yeah I
mean I think I don't know the exact
about the stellar-sized no massive
objects out there I don't know that I
mean there's some sort of suggestions
there's another planet out there a big
planet for example but you're right that
can be that can be stuff always in way
beyond the Kuiper belt and we're talking
you know a light year away or something
like that now it's it's interesting
because it's incomprehensible the
distance right and in our minds how far
that must be out past what we used to
call Pluto but for whatever reason that
becomes more interesting because it's in
our neighborhood whereas if they find
some distant star system and it might
have a planet that's similar to earth
that doesn't seem as compelling for
whatever weird reason no yeah I mean I
think the
the planets around Alpha Centauri
Proxima Centauri which are the closest
stars
it seemed like there are planets around
those now and then that that was
interesting because we could conceive of
going there right and there was this
idea you're Stephen Hawking actually and
some others before he died had this idea
called breakthrough starshot which is
the idea to send a little probe out so
at the sense at the Alpha Centauri
system and I think in their view yuri
milner as well the you know the
entrepreneur wanted to do that and there
is i think it's in like a hundred years
travel time or something with with with
our current technology and they pointed
out that yeah we don't do that now we
don't think hundred years in the future
but did we go back when people are
building cathedrals people used to
routinely start projects that would take
a hundred years to bear fruit yeah so we
could imagine going there and that's
that then becomes fascinating I think
because then you've got a solar system
another solar system that you could go
and visit conceivably conceivably yeah I
mean what kind of speed are we talking
and how long would it take to get there
well yeah I mean so it is I think that
the idea was about a hundred years to
get there so it's going yeah four light
years or so in a hundred years to
essentially do what they didn't like to
Ridley Scott alien film and put people
into some sort of a oh yeah it wouldn't
be a cruelty probe wouldn't be possible
for a crew well it is reason yeah that's
always that you know whenever you talk
to engineers you had a London use yes
engineer's always say you know
physicists go well it's possible in
principle so over to you you know there
are no laws of physics that tell us we
can't do it so we just do it right but
you know yeah but but yeah in principle
you're right if you can send a little
robot spaceship there you can send a
crude spaceship I am of the opinion as
time goes on and augmented and virtual
reality gets better and better that it
doesn't really totally make sense unless
we're talking about colonizing some
place to send biological life to another
planet if we can send some probe that
doesn't have to worry about
you know the biology being affected by
radiation or by the speed of travel or
even by food we can send something out
there and almost be there by virtue of
you know goggles virtual reality goggles
or something else yeah you hear that in
science at the moment space science we
have this debate a lot actually because
of course space probes like curiosity
that's on Mars at the moment that's
really cheap compared to sending people
to Mars and so quite often the
scientists who want to find out about
the worlds will say well we should spend
it on robots we shouldn't spend it on
people I think Croods face exploration
is in in some ways and it's clearly true
at the moment that humans can do more
than robots so we can explore the place
better for now yeah but but I think it
has to be it's about something else I
mean it's about and it's not only it's
about living and working off the planet
which I think it's quite persuasive
argument actually we've already
industrialized near Earth orbit so it's
already a multi-billion dollar industry
in every communication satellites and
weather satellites GPS whatever yeah
we're already up there and so learning
to live and work in space is I think a
natural extension of our of our
civilization plus the fact if you talk
to Ilana or Jeff Bezos they point out
that the amount of resources available
just slightly above our heads is vast
and so I remember I talked to Jeff Bezos
actually once and he he thinks really
simply and he said no for example in the
asteroid belt there's enough metal I
think to build a skyscraper what is it
something like 800 stories tall and
cover the earth in it right if you want
now we don't want to do that where's
point was that that the energy from the
Sun is all up there the resources are up
there so you could almost imagine trying
to zone the earth residential at some
point in the future to protect the
planets and do your heavy industry off
the planet for example and these sound
this sounds like science fiction except
that now SpaceX and Blue Origin those
people have got reusable rockets so
suddenly the economic
become sensible so I think it i think i
think expansion is good and I think we
will expand and I think we will expand
outwards because there's not much room
left on this planet to expand so I think
we'll do so but it's that's a whole
different idea it's not about gathering
scientific information it's about a
frontier and all the benefits that come
from operating as a civilization on the
frontier which we've lost on the earth
because there is no front to your left
and so I like that idea
mmm that Mars and when you talk about
Mars especially with Elon he's right
that that's the only place you can go so
the reason our the planet we can go to
other than Mars you can't go to Jupiter
or Saturn goes of mercury or Venus so if
we want to go somewhere and expand our
civilization it has to be Mars and
everything is there that you need so
with that that's a different thing
saying you want to find out stuff you're
right if we just want to find out stuff
then you send robots but as far as
expanding actual civilization and
bringing it to another place one of the
things that freaks me out is people get
depressed about living in Seattle I mean
you're gonna live on Mars I wouldn't I
really yeah it's if he had horrendous
thing it's like the like the Western
Front yes difference here when people
cross the States
yeah incredibly dangerous thing to do
across the states they still got to
Wyoming in beautiful places and Colorado
and yeah but it was hard yeah I wouldn't
wanted to do it but once you got there
there's a river and there's trout in the
river and then the meadows are green and
it's it's right I mean I I agree with
you right I mean I'm not gonna go that
of the ravine yards and hotels but
however it is true that there are people
who like the challenge and what is true
about Mars it's interesting actually
because we know something about the
history of Mars now quite a lot about
history of Mars and it's certainly clear
that there was water almost certainly
oceans and rivers so and that water is
almost certainly still there so I would
say certainly still there well they have
found large quantities of ice now right
yeah so there's certainly ice there may
even be pockets of liquid water below
the surface somewhere so a couple that
with all the the mineral
and the resources that we know are there
and you have everything you need so
that's the thing about masses it's quite
nice relative to everywhere else other
than the earth you can't go to Venus you
know you just melt it what is it
four hundred and something degrees and
ninety atmospheric pressures yes so so
so Mars is quite nice but I wouldn't go
there I agree with you because it was
not gravity of Mars in relationship to
it so yeah so it would still have a
significant like weakening effect like
if you went to Mars and then somehow or
another in the future they they were
able to get back to earth
yeah your body would have a real problem
with that right would but there there is
there is still grab my spent more than a
third I can't quite remember but it's
something like that but yeah so you
there's still gravity so there's gravity
there's some protection from the you'd
probably want to live in the caves
actually or something like that you'd
because there's no magnetic field there
so it's quite a high radiation
environment but not too bad it's further
from the Sun than we are
it's not - there are places on Mars that
there's a very deep crater called helis
which is a big impact basin and at the
bottom the the it's so deep you could
fit Everest in it so you put Mount
Everest in there the summit of Everest
wouldn't reach the rim of the crater so
it's just something like I don't know
what it is seven miles deep or somewhat
six miles deep so you could go there and
at the bottom the atmospheric pressure
is so high that you could just about
have liquid water occasionally on the
floor of that crater so it's quite water
sometimes it can be 20 degrees really
yeah Celsius Wow so right now exactly I
was experiencing a serious cold face
right so it can be warmer than Minnesota
and so there are places where it's not
horrendous or Mars you know so the
Martian it's it's kind of really sticky
nuts and sort of bits of it do you watch
those movies and shake your head I like
him I like science fiction you know so
yeah and it's it there I grew up with
Star Wars
that was my when I was 9 years old or
some finite
yeah I'm not having this I did an
argument with Neil deGrasse Titan on
argument but debate with him about
lightsabers once because I claimed that
they're physically probably in principle
there possible
and he was trying to say that down but
they are would they'd have to loop back
around cuz the light's not continuing
like the fact that it goes to a certain
distance and pauses we have a mirror or
something I guess yes something that's
pretty the end of it that's true so it
wouldn't be a different kind of light so
the only point I was making is that
photons particles of light can bounce
off each other hmm so we see that in
really high energy experiments in parts
of accelerators we can collide photons
together so my point was a bit of a
pedantic physicist one but he's because
he it is true that light can bounce off
it
it can hit light right but very very
high energy but when they press their
body to a certain yes I wasn't
that's engineering right I agree with
you I agree with you the distance to it
right so as you're swinging it around
you wouldn't have the leverage of a long
thing so why not make it really long
because it wouldn't be difficult to
swing around like you could stab someone
with a light saber a mile away that's
true
that's just a laser and yes why make it
so short
you have to swing you have to be close
to any person with it it's a silly silly
design you are picking holes correctly
in the engineering part of my the only
point I was making is the physics is
that which i think is quite interesting
his light can bounce off light yes so
but it would have to there would have to
be something that causes it to stop at
the very end yeah yeah yeah which would
be you're right it haven't merit but he
wouldn't look cool with it if there was
a no kind of thing with him what drives
me crazy about Star Wars is not the
lightsabers it's the lasers when they're
shooting the guns I'm like why can I see
that well I can't see bullets yeah this
is we're supposed to be way faster than
a bullet yeah
this because it's like they really slow
off that so angry I feel like this is so
dumb I could go warp speed in this
Millennium Falcon and travel the speed
of light but for whatever reason these
lasers are so slowly you could duck out
of the way of them that's so dumb and
it's not only Star Wars it's everything
every single film does that yeah yeah
it's like it's like films like also I
worked on one of these films years ago
sunshine very underappreciated movie
yeah I think so I think but in that so
they they asked me or Danny said I want
to do it right so I'll do the spacecraft
without any sound so when it's traveling
through space they'll be silent and it
looks [ __ ] you know just when you watch
it's the same when when you try and film
astronauts and you and they're in zero-g
and they always move slowly
yeah but it looks silly so this kind of
I suppose it's what audiences have got
used to over the years and so in the end
you happen 2001 which didn't do it
yeah silent in 2001 well Kubrick was a
stickler for science and for he was
apparently he would do complex
mathematics in his spare time
well fascinating guy that must have been
yeah I read that they just and someone
just found an interview didn't they the
other day where he explained the ending
of 2001 I didn't say that yesterday
actually and it was it was kind of a
really simple version of it he just said
well the super intelligent beings take
him in and put him in a zoo basically
and watch him grow old and then send him
back to the earth as a super being
that's the worst explanation at the end
of 2002 one I've ever heard but he was
Kubrick's that's what Kubek said so
there he falls into the monolith yet
they just put him in this room which is
kind of a bad version of a French
chateau or something watch him grow old
and then send him back to the earth is a
super being Wow okay that was Kubrick's
yeah
it's uh it's a it's a weird genre right
because sometimes people get things
right like didn't HG Wells predict a
significant amount of scientific
inventions in the future well there was
he said I mean depends which one doesn't
it there was a moon one wasn't though he
did M agenda to the moon I mean his time
machine is no right to do that really
worked out yet so yeah I think it's I I
always liked science fiction yeah I like
arthur c clarke a lot you know cuz i i
think it is you're right it's a a form
that you can let your imagination wander
and address things that restriction i
think did you like the alien series i
loved it yes I leave when I was at
school he's 1979 and we had a school
film Club in the 70s they weren't like
they are now we don't
so the first films they put on the three
films I was a 11 and it was alien
Apocalypse Now in Life of Brian Wow
which I that was my introduction to wow
those are three great choices but I feel
like really Scott's original alien is
probably one of the greatest horror
science fiction movies of all time one
of my all-time favorite movies but I
really like the newer ones as well like
Pete I like Prometheus and I really like
covenant the the last one
yeah Prometheus I don't know I yeah it's
not the best one I look they're like
what they're trying to do with it the
whole idea about the engineers coming
back in time and that's it that's why I
was disappointed with it because I
thought this set up the opening is
brilliant and I thought this is just
going to be brilliant right then I
thought it just lost its way and it was
a disappointment because it could have
been so brilliant yes I agree with you
yeah the beginning was fantastic but I
think covenant was more more exciting
and well it's also preposterous like if
you went to another planet like the last
thing you'd be doing is just breathing
in the air right I mean we'd have to be
really care if there was a life on the
planet
we'd have to be really careful not to
contaminate but be not to be
contaminated right yeah yeah I mean yeah
there's also I mean you know the other
thing in science fiction films is
gravity because you always yeah an alien
you always just say the spaceships got
gravity again there's only 2001 right
where everybody flows around yeah
because all has a spinning thing right
the spaceship has gravity and then when
you land the gravity is exactly like
Earth yeah perfect yeah you know yeah
what are the odds that you would find a
planet that is exactly like even if a
planet was one and a half times the size
of Earth it would have far more gravity
right and that's that's really common
for a planet to be like just a little
bit bigger yeah and then we would be
like the [ __ ] everywhere would be
walking with people we'd be getting
crushed right I agree with you yeah but
that's not the point it's about ideas
yes and you know this whole idea where
you're just supposed to let it let the
you know let the story play out and I
mean sunshine was and you know they put
the premise is is silly I mean it's the
premises the Sun is dying and we're
gonna go and fix it yeah so both of
those things it fails on its first line
a bit in the sense of realism but the
idea is that it's not about that it's
about it's about the it's about the Sun
as a God in some ways so it's about our
response to the power of nature and it's
about defying this thing and worshiping
it and how ultimately you go mad if you
remember the film there's pin backer
who's the first captain that went to the
captain the first mission to go and
restart the Sun which is the mad bit
mm-hmm but then became a religious
fundamentalist essentially and then
decided it's a fascinating idea that he
decides to bring meaning to his life he
will become the last the last man the
last human and so he wants to be the
last he wants the Sun to die and he
wants it to take humanity with it and he
decided to make that happen so he stays
there waiting for the second ship I like
those ideas that you know that what's
your reaction to the power of nature
this it after him one of the things that
in my shows I'm not being a commercial
person I just thought one of the great
things about cosmology is that it is
terrifying in the in the truest sense of
the word when we talked a bit about the
size and scale of the universe and black
holes come
those things you know it is very
frightening but also the I think the act
of trying to understand our place in
nature and the size and scale of the
universe now our your tiny presence
within it is valuable it's a it's a so
that you can be terrified but also
inspired and interested and it's part of
if you want to find if you want to ask
questions about what it means to be
human and means to be alive then I think
you find the answers in confronting that
reality which is that we live in a
terrifyingly vast universe the palette
powers in the universe that we cannot
comprehend as you said but that that
that's what you've got to face because
that's reality so you can't hide your
head in the sand and just duck it and it
sends some it can send some people crazy
I'm sure it is really interesting that
we need that suspension of disbelief in
order to sort of make a film on space
you you almost have to like oh well this
isn't really how it be but this is how
you have to make it in order to fit it
into a two-hour movie yeah and then and
then the film as we sunshine becomes
about you then you can have the film
about something else yes it's not really
about that well did you like a event
horizon yeah I did actually
I always wanted to ask about their their
concept of propulsion that you that
almost like space would be flat you
would fold space over and you would
intersect those two points and you would
be able to travel vast distances
instantaneously right and I'm doing a
terrible job of explaining I'm sure but
is that a concept that people have
actually considered yeah you can in in
general relativity so so I instance I
should say what it is Einsteins theory
general relativity is our best theory of
space and time and so it really is as we
talked about before it's you imagine
space and time as a sheet just imagine
it as a thing sort of literally a sheet
surface and all the theory says is that
if you put matter and/or energy into
that then it curbs it
and distorts it and it can stretch it
and make it shrink and so it's the
response of space and time to matter and
energy so if you if you the simplest
version will be the Sun so you put the
big spherical ball of stuff in there and
it warps face and time such that the
nice straight lines something just
traveling - Oh in business through that
warp space turns into an orbit and
that's why you can actually kind of see
things that are behind the Sun yeah okay
so light bends around the Sun because
it's just traveling through the curved
space the earth goes around the Sun
because it's just rolling minding its
own business through the curved space so
an example would be you might say well
how does a curved space
how does can that give rise to something
looks like a force she's gravity so the
best analogy I know of is to think of
walking around on the surface of the
earth so if you stand on the equator of
the earth and you'd you with your friend
and you say we're gonna walk Joo North
so we're gonna set off let's say we're a
thousand miles apart on the equator and
we're gonna walk Joo North and what's
going to happen so you walk in straight
lines you don't change direction you
don't give any accelerating but the
straight lines are lines of longitude on
the surface of the earth so as you go
further and further north you get closer
and closer together and if you carry on
to the pole you bump into each other
mm-hmm but nothing's happened
no one's know and there's no forces
acting it's just that you're moving on a
curved surface and so you get closer and
that's basically Einstein's theory of
general relativity now why did I start
talking about event horizon the idea of
oh yeah so so you can so all you have to
do so that those folded kind of
geometries is you have to try and
specify how where you would put the
matter and what kind of stuff you'd put
there to make the geometry fold in that
way and you can do it you can do it so
you can you can write down that geometry
it's called a warp drive geometry I
think is called that is in textbooks so
you can do that to have a warp drive the
question becomes what sort of stuff
would you have to actually put into the
real universe to make it warp in that
way and it always it usually turns out
that
the kind of stuff that doesn't exist
right but it has properties it's math
sort of matter or sort of energy that
has properties that do not exist in
nature as far as we can tell but you can
still write the geometry down in
Einstein's theory so if you had mystical
force or mass or whatever it is if you
had that stuff that doesn't exist it is
a concept that yeah so the geometry
exists so you can you can you can do it
and you can do the calculations and you
can see the warp drive you can construct
wormholes that connect distant regions
of the universe which you could use as
time machines and you can do all that in
the theory but in nature you'd have to
have the right stuff to do it but that
stuff is not real that seems to be as
far as we know yeah now what would have
to happen like the you would have to
have enough power or mass to be able to
fold those two things together like it
tends to be weird stuff like an stuff
that has a negative pressure or
something like that so stuff that has
physical properties that are just
bizarre
and that no matter our energy that we
know of in the universe has so that that
to make to make the geometry happen but
it's conceivable in theory that this
could exist even though it doesn't it's
it it said it said the very altom utley
and so wormholes are a good example so
that would be quite literally it we've
talked about the surface of the earth so
you fly to Australia from LA and you
have to go quite a long way around this
edge of the earth oh you could tunnel
straight through and get there quicker
see that's a worse name he's got a
little graphic up there and there it is
so you could go all the way around the
edge or you could cut take the shortcut
so the question it's so you can do that
in Einstein's theory you can write down
that geometry and there it is so the
first question is can you make it and as
we've said we don't think that stuff
exists there's a second set of
theoretical bits of theoretical work
which if you had a wormhole then what
would happen if you tried to travel
through it and what seems to happen is
that is that they become unstable the
moment anything tries to go through so
you get kind of a feed
if still going through and through and
through and through and so it collapses
and that there's a great this great book
by Kip Thorne actually we just mentioned
him he got the Nobel Prize last year for
the gravitational waves and he wrote a
brilliant blog links in the 80s called
black holes and time warps way talks
about the the answer is we don't fully
know but most physicists think that even
if they existed they would be unstable
then as soon as you even try to transmit
information through them send a bit of
light through then there will be this
sort of feedback and they'd collapse and
ultimately the reason we don't really
know absolutely is because you need
what's called a quantum theory of
gravity and we don't have one so we
don't have the theoretical tools to be
absolutely sure that these things would
be unstable or don't exist in nature but
we strongly suspect that they don't they
did you could build a time machine so
there Stephen Hawking wrote a paper
called the chronology protection
conjecture and conjecture is the
important word so we conjecture
basically was that the laws of nature
will be such that you can't have stable
wormholes and you can't build time
machines
and if you send something through it it
would destabilize ya and if it didn't
destabilize it how would your physical
body deal with the stress of that well
it doesn't have to be that you can you
can build them that's called the tidal
gravitational force so it's the
difference in gravitational pull across
your body which is one of the things
that gets you fall into a black hole so
before you actually get to the
singularity you can get its cause
spaghettified yes it's certainly cool so
you get it's just like the moon's you
know the tidal effects on the earth
which is quite small but they still
raise tides on the oceans so that can be
a if you think about something like a
black hole that can be a massive
difference in gravitational pull from
your head to your feet and so it can
stretch you out and so but you can with
wormholes you you can you can write the
geometry down the United States theory
so that you could go through so so you
don't have to be destroyed of anything
weird happen to you would you have to
have some something protecting you some
force some some sort of
just literally fall through I mean it so
you know if they were they would exist
you just you just go through you sit in
a little spaceship but you you you
wouldn't there's nothing inherently in
them that says that you would be ripped
apart but what are your thoughts on on
alien life on life outside of this
planet something you think about yeah I
think there must be even in the solar
system I would not be surprised if we
find microbes on Mars or some of the
moons of Jupiter or Saturn where there's
liquid water like Europa yeah and the
reason is if you think about the reason
I think that it's a guess it's because
if you look at the history of life on
Earth then so earth formed and it was
just a there was no life he was a ball
of rock and almost as soon as it cooled
down we see evidence of life so
certainly 3.8 billion years ago possibly
even further back them there we see
evidence of life on Earth so somewhere
along the line geochemistry active
geochemistry became biochemistry on
earth and we have some idea you know
that if you get gradients of temperature
and acid and alkaline and the conditions
that are naturally present on the
surface of oceans then complex carbon
chemistry spontaneously happens so we
have a we know that life almost
certainly we know that life began on
earth I mean he had the other option is
it came from space or something like
that but he probably didn't probably
probably began on earth and so that
means that at least here that happened
and that we know that the conditions
that led to the origin of life on Earth
were present on Mars 3.8 before billion
years ago and we know that they're
present on your own for today so I don't
see that there's anything special
life is just chemistry and it and the
the idea that geochemistry becomes
biochemistry is not fanciful because it
happened here so I think that given the
same conditions
it would be surprising to me of the same
thing didn't happen in that life begins
so III that's one of the two tests that
is one of the great frontiers of science
now one of the great challenges which is
why another reason we're interested in
Mars because we know those conditions
were there we know there were what's
called hydrothermal vent systems on the
floors of oceans on Mars 3.8 or 4
billion years ago so it would be good to
know II what I've said is right and the
way we find out is to find life or
evidence of past life are you aware of
the speculation that was going around
how was it that occupy thing the octopus
eggs they there was a group of
scientists that were speculating that
it's pop you know panspermia the idea of
panspermia that it's possible that
octopi had come from somewhere else some
frozen eggs had actually come from
somewhere else and and landed on earth
and these are like legitimate scientists
are contemplated not morons I don't
think I've seen this the now I didn't
but I mean it I think suddenly so
panspermia doesn't have to be unlikely
right I mean for example you might seen
the other day we found an earth rock on
the moon
yes right well the earth now because he
probably know it's probably back didn't
they missed four billion years old or
something one of the oldest rocks ever
found yeah so we know that material gets
transferred between planets and so it's
not inconceivable that microbes could
survive that journey we know that
microbes can survive in space for
example so that isn't mad it's probably
unlikely but he's not mad but with the
octopus
I didn't heard that but the thing is
that the octopus is still extremely
similar biologically to us I mean the
differences are negligible yeah so it's
still got the same energy system with a
single ATP in DNA you know aster it's
all very very similar it was something
about RNA and DNA did you find that
article I'm looking at a different one
for certain websites about the same
thing I did with the Cambrian explosion
and there were 33 authors on a paper
that got published in the progress and
biophysics and molecular biology that
talked about this possibility there are
other people that disagree with it
though I mean I suppose the I haven't
seen it
so I think it's unlikely because the
octopus is extremely similar to us so
that suggests a common origin to me
there suppose the counter-argument you
could you could advance would be there's
only one way to do life so you could say
they're actually given because the laws
of physics and chemistry are the same
everywhere so maybe it's maybe DNA is
the only way to do it so that's the way
it gets done which is why they're so
similar to us yes all those so alien as
well yeah they're not though you know
that's the thing about so that's why I'm
surprised about it because they're not
that alien they're very similar well
there are in their abilities I mean
their ability to transform their outer
texture and their color instant almost
instantaneously oh yeah I mean they have
incredible camouflage abilities that
really don't exist in the mammalian
world yeah but I'll sell you a level you
look at an octopus cell in among under a
microscope and you wouldn't be able to
tell the dish
so you know it's for sale and humans so
the only way that that would make sense
as if all life comes from basically the
same kind of building blocks and just
varies depending upon the conditions and
where it takes place
I'm guessing but yes that must be the
the only way you could sustain that
given that they're so similar see was
because they really are biochemically is
that that's the only way it can be done
given the given the building block the
toolkit the laws of nature and the the
elements and so on that we have in our
universe we have so many different life
forms on our planet but if we found
anything that's remotely similar to what
we have here on earth
on another planet it would be such an
incredible discovery like we sent if we
found a frog on the moon I mean the
world would stop right I'd be very
surprised if we found anything anywhere
that is any in any way similar an insect
on Mars well this is I mean it as I said
it be micro I didn't be single-celled
things remember I mean you mentioned the
Cambrian explosion so that is that what
we do know that Earth is that although
life began let's say 3.9 billion years
ago it wasn't until around 600 million
years ago or so that or maybe most seven
hundred that you see any complex
multicellular organisms that's all
so first something like 3 billion years
it was single-celled alone and that's
one of the reasons why I would guess if
I had to guess I would say that microbes
would be common because life began very
quickly on earth and I would be
surprised to find it on Mars but complex
life multicellular life insects plants
intelligence
I would guess will be very rare because
it took so long on earth to get there
who doesn't slime about 3 billion years
of slime that was it what happened how
did it go from slime to giraffes
it's a very quickly once it once it got
going
yeah and it's one of the great unsolved
mysteries in biology the one thing that
is true is that we seem to be all
complex creatures seem to be we call
eukaryotes right rusa cells with a cell
nucleus and all that kind of stuff and
they look like they're the merger
between two simpler life-forms bacteria
and a thing called an archaea and our
Keun so it looks like somewhere in two
billion years ago whatever it was in
some ocean the bacterial cell got inside
the archein and survived as a symbiotic
organism essentially and then somehow
unbelievably managed to reproduce and
replicate in that configuration and that
does seem to be the origin of all
complex multicellular life on Earth so
it's called the fateful encounter
hypothesis and then if that's true then
it's just a bit of look any happen once
right and that's why we're here now when
lined look consider like how many
billion earth-like planets did you say
exist just our solar system alone in the
galaxy 20 billion something like that so
well intense towers so the odds of
complex life out of our incredibly
fortunate situation but the odds of that
occurring on any of these billions of
other planets that exist we don't know
but let's say the earth is let's say it
was on the fortunate side so we're with
talking about give or take four billion
years right from the origin of life to
now and we have a civilization now and
we've had it our species have been
around what a quite a million years or
something so it's just now basically so
let's say four billion is on the
fortunate side let's say that it was
double that or triple that on the
average suddenly that's the age of the
universe right that's a third of the age
of the universe so how many of those
worlds have been stable for three or
four billion years that that's quite a
tall order actually it looks like our
solar system might be quite unusual in
that respect because it could the
planets got to remain stable in a stable
orbit the Stars got to remain stable the
large mean stabilizes yeah Jupiter plays
a big role
take some roots yeah sucks a moon so and
that you know that there's a thing
there's a theory called the grand tech
theory which is so it's very hard to
explain the evolution of our solar
system so that when you do computer
models of solar systems you don't tend
to get for rocky planets too close to
the Sun and for big gas giants further
out and one of the current best theories
and this I say this because it shows you
how look you we might be is that Jupiter
that they tend to form these big gas
giants and migrated inwards towards the
star so you know I must all the computer
simulations just because you've got this
big gas giant orbiting all the dust
around the star they tend to drop
inwards and it looks like Jupiter did
that so it looks like it formed and came
in and came in almost to where Mars
orbits today and and cleared out the
region around Mars actually which is
maybe the reason Mars is so small
compared to the other so it's a Venus
and Earth oh but then Saturn was coming
in as well and in the computer models
the interaction between Jupiter and
Saturn stopped Jupiter coming in before
it gets to the earth and they both get
dragged out again and so it to where
they are today and so that and that that
seems to be it's one of the best
theories for the evolution of our solar
system so what are the chances you know
that the chances of that are so mini
school might tiny so
that's the thing I think about these
rocky planets you in order to get a
civilization on them I think you need I
guess you need quite unusual solar
systems and that would be a guess and
you need quite unusual stability on the
planet for billions of years and that's
why I think we might be quite lucky mmm
and how does bodes law work bodes law is
a method of detecting if you look at the
mass of a planet you can accurately
detect how much mass and the size of a
neighboring planet I think it wasn't
just the positions of the orbits I think
right where it is yeah
and it's one thing that is true about
our solar system is that you if you get
the computer simulations you can't put
more planets in if you try and fill put
more planets in they become it becomes
unstable very quickly so that the mass
of like if you measure Mars you can
accurately depict where the next planet
close to it would be it it was I mean it
was that's what was done was it 17th
century or so long yeah it was just one
of those things where you know it's a
pattern they were just trying to fit
just a pattern which is an you know not
there's nothing to that really other
than to say that most simulations of the
solar system if there are if you put
other planets in they tend to get thrown
out by gravitational interactions so
there is a sense in which our solar
system has got as much stuff in it as it
could have so the planets are nicely
spaced and you're right given the mass
of them that depends on how close
another planet can be before the
interaction goes wrong and it gets
thrown out into the intergalactic space
I some because mannix do that you know
we we know that planets get thrown out
of solar systems by gravitational
interactions so yeah so it again it
points to the fact that solar systems
are not are not stable over long periods
of time they're not like clockwork
things not like you know Newtonian
clockwork and it just goes on forever
they're not like that that they evolve
and planets can shift orbits and change
and one we know
you look at the surface of the Moon for
example it's covered in craters and that
was cause they all seem to hit about the
same time and it's about 3.8 billion
years ago or so and that's called the
late heavy bombardment so we know that
if you look at cratering rates on Mars
and on the moon
it all seems happening this all but a
big peak around that time and that seems
to be correlated with Neptune moving
outwards in the solar system and into
Kuiper belt basically are towards the
Kuiper belt and causing all sorts of
havoc and everything comes into the
inner solar system so those things
happen and it but it didn't happen when
life was established on the earth so
it's all extremely old stuff that this
is shifting textbook but how long is how
long's the solar system been in this
particularly stable situation that's in
now it's it's since about 3.8 billion
years ago so if it had been unstable at
any point since then
then we likely wouldn't be here right do
you think that it's possible do you ever
entertain the idea that it's possible
that we are the only intelligent life in
the known universe III like I said
Teresa I tend to restrict myself to the
galaxies so I do think it's possible
that at the moment there's one
civilization in the Milky Way and that's
us and I think that's important actually
and it goes back to our saying to start
about the astronomy and cosmology being
part the framework within which you have
to think if you're looking for meaning
you're looking for how we should behave
even politically you know the that has a
bearing to me
I mean imagine that we're the only place
where there is intelligence in this
galaxy and how should we behave
should we actually notwithstanding the
fact that we're tiny and fragile things
and insignificant physically should we
consider ourselves extremely valuable in
that respect because there's nowhere
else where you know the the I would go
as far as to say there would be nowhere
elsewhere meaning exists in the Milky
Way meaning because meaning it's one of
those things that scientists don't talk
about very much although Richard Fineman
one of my great heroes did
talk about it there's a quote where he
says what is the meaning of it all it's
a great essay called the value of
science and so what is self-evidently
true is that meaning exists here because
it means something to us so that's kind
of a an obvious statement your life
means something to you and me and so
meaning exists but I think it is a local
and temporary phenomenon I think it's it
emerges meaning emerges from
configurations of atoms which is what we
are we are simply that we nothing more
than that we're very very rare
configurations of atoms I think and so
that means that we are if you go all the
way down that line of logic we are the
only Island meaning in the galaxy I'm
meaning only to ourselves yeah it means
something to us because we're the only
ones who can grasp the concept and we
are finite we are finite organism we
have this temporary existence while
we're here and to us there is meaning
yeah and that's I don't know any other
way to define it right so I'll define it
like that yes I don't think there's a
globe yeah otherwise you have to believe
there's some kind of global meaning and
that's a god type mingun I don't think
that's I think it's more wonderful and
and more challenging to us because we
have to take responsibility for it to
say we should operate such that we are
it in this galaxy mmm there's nothing
else I'm sure I'm just I'm sure there
are other civilizations out there in the
universe because there are two trillion
galaxies I I just can't believe this
hasn't happened in other places the
question is how often does it happen and
how widely spaced our civilizations and
I think they're very widely spaced and I
think there may be one or two per galaxy
on the average I could but that as you
said it that what you said it basically
that what else can we think right well
then what else do you want I mean I
think what it says is you have to take
responsibility for all those things as
spiritual things that you think about
and the emotional things you think about
it you you are you are responsible for
that you are that like that whatever
that is
it exists in you and it will only exist
for short amount of time
and so what you know make the best of it
it'll be my it's so unbelievably
compelling though to consider the idea
that somewhere out there there's another
civilization that maybe even more
advanced than us and this this thought
of it it's just so attractive it's it's
it's incredible that [ __ ] there should
be if if civilizations are common or
even slightly common then there should
be civilizations ahead of us yes because
there's been so much time but wouldn't
you want to see what that's like yeah I
mean we so compelling you imagine the
timescales we've been around as a
civilization let's let's give it say
forty thousand years I don't know long
our civilization has been around let's
say that the the galaxy is pretty much
as old as the universe it's thirteen
billion years worth of time so the idea
that there are no no civilization zeros
you know 100 million years ago 200
million years ago
1 billion years ago and imagine what
they'd be like if they'd survived I mean
we've been we've been around we've had
science for let's say since Newton or
Copernicus 500 years at most we've had
Sun look what we've done we've gone
beyond the solar system with Voyager
we've walked on the moon and we're about
to go to Mars I would think so we're
about to begin colonizing our own solar
system and so we've done that in 500
years so imagine a million years in the
future
so I would it's one of the arguments
often used to say there aren't any
civilizations out there in the galaxy
it's called the Fermi paradox because if
you imagine a civilization that's a
million years ahead of us they should
have written their presence across the
sky by now they should used to see him I
mean you'll see us leave we survived a
million years into the future actually
even a few thousand years into the
future we will be exploring the galaxy
we will have spacecraft that are going
to of the stars we will be doing it so
our signature will become visible I'm
sure if we last
into the medium said would we choose to
not do that here's my thought on that is
uncontacted tribes like do you know
about the the gentleman who was the
missionary who visited North Sentinel
island yeah it was killed by the natives
North Sentinel island which is a really
unusual place because they branched off
from Africa 60,000 years ago and they've
been living on this one small ion the
size of Manhattan and as well as we know
there's only about 39 of them left
somewhere around there
and we can't we're not supposed to
contact them like people are not
supposed to like leave them alone and
there are a rare tribe when they find
them in the Amazon the uncontacted
tribes our initial instinct is back off
leave them alone
leave them alone do you think that
perhaps a universe like if there is a
civilization that's a million times more
advanced than awesome been around here
for you know millions of years of life
as opposed to quarter million why would
they why would they let us know like
will they look at us dropping bombs on
each other and polluting the ocean
sucking all the fish out and putting
clouds into the skies of dirt and
particles and why would they look at
these crude monkeys look at their data
they're so far beyond where they need to
be before they could join the Galactic
Civilizations
it is true it's an argument that there
is an argument as well that it
technology's so advanced would be
difficult for us to detect I mean we
tend to think of you know when you say
written across the sky I suppose it's
true I'm thinking of starships like Star
Wars right big energy things that you
can see the signature of but actually
maybe the civilization just becomes a
nano civilization a tiny little nano but
because that's more inefficient it's a
better way to do things
so it's possible I suppose then there
are space probes all over the place
they're so small and it's so efficient
and use so little energy that we just
don't see them I suppose that is
possible my other thought is that where
we are headed it seems to me that
there's some sort of a strange symbiosis
that's taking place there's there's a
strange connection that we have to
electronics and ultimately to an
artificial creation or
official intelligence whatever you want
to call an artificial light life
something that's created by carbon-based
beings
cellular beings that isn't cellular but
also acts like life yeah that this may
be the future of life that we are so
connected to the idea of flesh and blood
and bone but maybe this is just a
temporary situation until we transition
or if not us transition till it
surpasses us and this is the next stage
of life but this stage has no need for
all the human and biological reward
systems are in place that made sure that
we survive whether it's ego or fear or
emotions no need for that
that it will just exist and maintain its
equilibrium as this this new form of
life and this is the future of life in
the universe and it will get there maybe
we'll only be a hundred two hundred
years from now but that that's what
exists all throughout the cosmos so
there's no need to peacock there's no
need to show our sin on the sky and that
it just exists in this form yeah I agree
I wouldn't be surprised yes that's the
that's the counter-argument to the this
Fermi paradox argument that I talks
about well exactly as you've just said
there basically you evolved to a point
very rapidly where you just don't create
a signature yes and you don't really get
involved as you said maybe just yeah
well there's no motivation right like it
doesn't our motivations are also weird
right we have these biological
motivations to survive and you know
there's motivations to conquer and to
innovate and to spread our genes and to
move into New Territories but if you
didn't have biology if you were you
existed completely from man-made
materials or from materials found on
earth and that this new form of life was
created out of that I wouldn't have
those unless you programmed them and why
would you do that
it is interesting isn't it too because
we don't know what consciousness is
right so something called a hard problem
in science we don't know so
it's a good question whether you can
build let's say you want to build a
self-replicating machine which is what
you're talking about or something that
can go and maybe go to the moon on Mars
and replicate itself and then carry on
which is a living thing I suppose yes
does it have to have a sufficient level
of intelligence very actually is
conscious and all these things that we
talked about this this word meaning that
we used earlier that we all understand
you can't define is that a emergent
property that that has to emerge if
you've got something that's intelligent
enough to replicate itself and live and
run you said be there I don't know the
answer but it's worth considering that
this thing this what we emotion meaning
love and fear and all those things are
just the things that happen when you are
intelligent right I don't know the
answer to that but it could possibly be
and does consciousness have to have a
local origin like it does it have to
come from a thing like if you think
about cellular communication the the if
you send me if you're in England can you
send me a video from your phone and it
reaches my phone it's getting to me
through space it's going through the sky
it's like literally from a device not
connected by any wires or anything it's
coming to me
if if there's a possibility to create
some sort of global intelligence through
electronics that's non-local if one
piece of it falls off there's the same
it is it just repairs itself or figures
itself out but it's the same
consciousness existing on a global scale
through some sort of an electronic
network that instead of the idea that
you and I have that Brian and Joe are do
you have your mind I have my mind and we
we exist as intelligent being separate
from each other but instead of that that
all of it is connected and that all of
it is something that we can't even
conceive of because our brains are too
crude like trying to explain to you know
Australia Pittacus what a satellite is
yeah
yeah I mean yes I mean if you think
about our brains they are ultimately
what are they they're just a distributed
network of cells connected by neurons
and I mean they're very complicated but
they are a colony of things that are
autonomous in a sense and they're
communicating with each other so yeah I
don't I don't see why you can't scale
that up in principle I mean I should
just err the caveat is always that we
don't know we don't yes it's easy it's
just not understood well I think there's
something weird has physics although I'm
damn sure it's physical I'm damn sure
that there's nothing going on in my head
other than what is allowed by the laws
of nature as we understand them I'm sure
you mean the idea of a soul being some
sort of a divine thing that's inside the
housing of the body yeah I mean I I know
I would say we can rule that out
actually
I've out in the past how do you rule it
I've argued we can rule that out in the
following manner so so it's my arm right
so it's made of electrons and protons
and neutrons and if I if I have a soul
in there something that we don't
understand but it's a different kind of
energy or whatever it is first we don't
have in physics at the moment it
interacts with matter because I'm moving
my hand around so whatever it is it's
something that interacts very strongly
with matter but if you look at the
history of particle physics in
particular which is the study of matter
we spend we spent decades making
high-precision measurements of how
matter behaves and interacts and we look
for it for example for a fifth force of
nature so we know four forces for
gravity the two nuclear forces call the
weak and strong nuclear forces and
electromagnetism and that's what we know
exists and we look for another one with
ultra-high precision and we don't see
any evidence of it so I would claim that
we know how matter interacts at these
energies it's a room temperature now
these Angele we know how matter
interacts very precisely and so if you
want to suggest there's something else
that interacts with matter strongly then
I would say that it's ruled out I would
go as far to say it is ruled out by
experiments
or at least is his extremely subtle and
you would have to jump through a lot of
Hoops to come up with a theory of some
stuff that we wouldn't have seen when
we've observed how matter interacts that
is present in our bodies and presumably
we believe in the soul you want it to
exist outside when you die you still
want the thing to be there and you might
believe in ghosts and things like that
like a ghost I mean it's a it is
something that carries the imprint of
you presumably it looks like you right
so that means that it interacts strongly
with the matter that is you because it
carries a patent if it carries a pattern
it carries information if it carries
information there has to be an energy
source that allows that information to
persist in the pattern to persist and so
on so again you end up with a a theory
that is postulating something it
interacts with light because if you
think a ghost is the soul then it's
something that people see sometimes so
that means it interacts with light but
we know how light interacts and we ruled
out anything but the most subtle further
interaction that we haven't seen so I
would I claim and I started off as a
joke this actually I wrote it in an
infinite monkey cage book this radio
show that I do but he ended up when I'd
written it down I thought actually that
it makes sense and I read some is
similar actually I think I'm Sean
Carroll II I don't have you've had Sean
yes shareable dumps he he's said
something the same I think in the book
they wrote the big picture I think he
has a similar argument actually so it's
occurred to him as well it's roughly the
same argument so if you so this energy
that's interacting with matter even if
you're not moving at all if you're just
thinking it's interacting with the
matter that encompasses your mind or
your brain or your nerves or your
neurons yeah it's something in there
that's interacting with matter whether
you like it or not so even just a simple
thought process or a dream is still
something that's interacting with Matt
yeah well obviously because it you know
you your will isn't it presumably right
so even but even if you're not moving
the idea like the you're saying you're
like your body's interacting with matter
as you're moving your arm but even if
you're not moving if you
just thinking and you're completely
still which is not totally possible cuz
your hearts beating and your breathing
and all that stuff but if somehow or
another you were able to isolate just
the thought the thoughts themselves are
still interacting with matter because
they're interacting with the brain
itself
yeah so there's something in there
there's something that interacts with
the physical structure of your body and
and and I would say there isn't so
that's the whoo-whoo version is that the
brain itself and the body the physical
so this this this spiritual self you are
merely an antenna that's tuning into the
the the great consciousness of the
universe but why but then you have to
answer what it we know what we are made
of yes oh we know how those particles
behave and interact so so why do the
particles not in any way interact with
that stuff because we interact we don't
if that's true we don't only just
interact with it we interact extremely
strongly with it we're interacting with
it now yeah every movement I make is the
interaction between those every matter
yeah yes what everything if I move my
fingers everything that I'm doing right
is an interaction between that stuff and
me so it's a very strong interaction
with matter but we don't see it in all
our precision measurement well the
answer for that dancer is because it's
not there the answer is Jesus and you
can't measure God that may be an answer
but the point is you as we talked about
earlier with absolute space yeah if you
can't measure it yeah it's not there hmm
right it's but for whatever reason for
people there is some incredible
motivation to find a divine something or
another that's there's something greater
than this physical being there's
something what do you think that is like
what is that compulsion we we've already
sort of talked a bit about it I think it
goes to the the hearts of this question
of what it means to be human
mmm
so I would say that being human the
answer to the it's not the answer to the
meaning but it an answer would be we are
small finite beings right which are just
clusters of atoms as we said before
they're very rare but we understand
roughly how they how they came to be and
we have a limited amount of time not
actually unfortunately but because of
the laws of nature that the laws of
nature forbid us to be immortal
they-they-they immortality's ruled out
by the laws of physics but also actually
what's interesting about if you look at
the basic physics of the universe going
from the Big Bang to where we are today
then the physics is driven by the fact
that the universe began in an extremely
ordered state so it was a very highly
ordered system and it is tending towards
a more disordered system at the moment
and that's called the second law of
thermodynamics and it's that basic
common-sense thing that things go to
[ __ ] basically the second law of
thermodynamics what we strongly suspect
and and I would say know is that in that
process of going from order to disorder
complexity emerges naturally for a brief
period of time so it's a natural part of
the evolution of the universe that you
get appeared in time when there's
complexity in the universe so stars and
planets and galaxies and life and
civilizations but they are they exist
because the universe is decaying not in
spite of the fact the universe is
decaying so our existence in that sort
of picture is necessarily finite and
necessarily time limited and it is a
remarkable thing that that complexity
has got so far that there are things in
the universe that can think and feel and
explore it and I think that is the
answer if you want an answer to the
meaning of it all it's that that you are
part of the universe because of the way
the laws of nature work
you are allowed to exist but you're
allowed to exist for a temporary or a
small amount of time in a possibly
infinite universe
one of the biggest mind-blowing moments
I think of my limited comprehension of
what it means to be a living being was
when I found out that carbon and all the
stuff that makes us has to come out of a
dying star yeah like there that alone
that there's this very strange cycle of
these enormous fireballs that Forge the
material that makes Brian Cox yeah like
what that that one alone that there is
some strange loop of biological life
that comes from stars which is like the
most elemental thing that we can observe
we see these things in this can we see
the Sun in the sky it's this
all-powerful ball of fire
yeah and that that is where the building
blocks for a person come from and then
is it so and they will be from the
carbon atoms in our body that you're
right they all got made in styles
because there were none of it at the Big
Bang
there's only hydrogen and helium tiny
bit of lithium to be precise but nothing
else and so it was all made in stars and
it's probably from different styles you
know the atoms in your body they're not
all from one star that cooks it and then
died there'll be a mixture of stuff from
many stars in your body now and I agree
with you the what more do you want you
know when I see people who got I want
more than that I want you know it was
there must be more to it
what do you mean the the we have we have
we were the ingredients now bodies were
assembled in their hearts of long dead
stars over billions of years and have
assembled themselves spontaneously into
temporary structures that can think and
feel and explore and then those
structures will decay away again at some
point and in a very far future there'll
be no structures left so there we are we
exist in this little window when we can
observe this magnificent universe why do
you want any more insults I think to
people I think a lot of people aren't
aware of
all the all the information right and
then I think on top of it for some
people it's just it's so overwhelming
you know this this concept of 13.8
billion years of everything to get to
this point that we're at right now it's
so overwhelming that they want to
simplify it you want to put it into some
sort of a fable structure something
where it's something that's very common
and similar and familiar yeah I I agree
and and but I think that's the the it's
the the the journey that we go on the
real treasure I think is in that journey
of trying to face the incomprehensible
yes it's it's in that realization that
it's almost it's it's almost impossible
to believe that we exist that's that's
that's a wonderful thing yeah and I
think that that's what I think you miss
out I think if you decide to simplify it
because you don't want to face that you
don't have faced the infinity that's out
there in front of us and you don't want
to face those stories as you said that
you look at your finger and its
ingredients was cooked in multiple stars
over billions of years that that's a to
me a joyous and powerful thing to think
about yes and I think you're missing out
if you don't want to face that well I
think the distribution of information
has changed so radically over the last
couple hundred years and particularly
over the last twenty that you're seeing
these trends now where more people are
inclined to abandon a lot of the even if
you remain religious or remain you keep
a sought or a belief in a higher power
people are more inclined to entertain
these concepts of science and to take in
the understanding of what has been
observed and documented and written
about among scholars and academics and
there's more there's more people
accepting that have you look at the
number of agnostic people now as opposed
to twenty thirty years ago it's it's
it's rising
it's changing and I think there's also
because of you and because of Neil
deGrasse Tyson and you know Sean Carroll
and all these other people that are
public intellectuals that are discussing
this kind of stuff people like myself
have a far greater understanding of this
then I think people did 30 40 years ago
yeah and that trend is continuing I
think in a very good direction yeah I
mean I don't you know what we should say
is that science we don't know all the
answers so we don't know where the laws
of nature came from we don't know why
the universe began in the way that it
did if indeed it had a beginning so I
don't know why the Big Bang was very
very highly ordered which is ultimately
as Sean Carroll actually mentioned him
often points out means right but the
whole difference the only difference
between the past in the future the
so-called arrow of time is that in the
past the universe was really ordered and
it's getting more disordered and that's
that that that necessary state of order
at the start of the universe which is
really the reason that we exist that's
the reason because the universe began in
a particular form we don't know why that
was so we will probably find out at some
point and it will be something to do
with the laws of nature but so I'm
always careful I don't want to science
can sometimes sound arrogant right it
can sometimes sound like it's the it's
the discipline of saying to people while
you're not right yeah and it's not the
discipline of saying you're not right
it's saying this is what we found out
yeah so I like to say that it provides a
framework within which if you want to
philosophize or you want to do theology
or you want to you want to ask these
deep questions about why we're here you
have to operate within that framework
because it's just an observational
framework yes everything we've said is
stuff we've discovered it's not stuff
that someone made up we we we you know
we understand nuclear physics we can
build nuclear reactors for example so we
understand the physics of stars so we
understand that the Stars built the
carbon oxygen and we know how they did
it and we can see it because as I said
before we can
if you look far out into the universe
you're looking way back in time and as
you look back in time you see less
carbon and less oxygen so we have a
direct observation that in the earliest
universe there wasn't any because we can
see it and now we see that there is some
and we know how it was made so I think
it's so it's important to be humble when
you're talking about science and you're
not saying this is the way that it is I
mean your own a sense but you know it's
not it's not able to answer ultimate
questions at the moment it's not able to
answer even whether the universe had a
beginning or not we don't even know that
and I gave a talk to him I was asked to
give a talk to some bishops in the UK
about cosmology and I said yeah that'd
be great fun and so when I gave him this
talk and at the end I said I've got some
questions so if the universe is eternal
and it might be it might not have had a
beginning if it's eternal what place is
there for a creator you know that's
that's a good question Brian I didn't
they didn't have an answer of course
right an eternal creator but yeah but I
think that these it might be eternal and
we might discover that so we don't know
at the moment but we might so I think my
point is that these other human desires
very natural to religions and natural
thing right people you see all across
the world in all different cultures but
I think that in the 21st century it
religion needs to operate within that
framework if it's going if it's going to
operate there are still great mysteries
and it is appropriate to think about
what it means to be human and are giving
you my view of what it means but but I
don't think the problem comes when you
when your your theology or your
philosophy forces you to deny some facts
some measurement now these things at
measurements we're not saying it's not
my opinion the universe is 13.8 billion
years old we measured it it's like
having an opinion between the distance
from LA to New York no you can't have an
opinion on that right know what it is
and it's the same you know excited out
that these things
people say the Earth's flat or whatever
there so it isn't and we've measured it
so it's just stop it either said but
that doesn't mean you can't be spiritual
and you can't be really just I would
saying it doesn't mean you can't believe
in God or God's
that's not ruled out by science but some
stuff's ruled out well I love the way
you communicate this because it takes
into consideration human nature and like
I love Dawkins he's fantastic I think
he's very very very valuable but he
likes to call people idiots and the
problem with that is people go [ __ ] you
you're an idiot it like is a natural
inclination when you insult people to
argue back and to sort of dig their
heels in yeah and you don't do that and
I think that's very important and I
think that a guy like doc has just gets
frustrated from all these years of
debates with people who educated are
saying ridiculous things and he's a bit
of a curmudgeon you know and he seems to
be softening as he's getting older well
he's the evolutionary biology yes and
that's the the front line in some sense
isn't it yes yeah I mean the thing about
particle physics is that you don't get a
lot of [ __ ] because people don't
understand what you're talking about
right there so I understand his
frustration oh I do too
having said that you know I've kind of
softened a bit over the years actually
because now I think at this point both
in the u.s. actually and in Britain and
in some of the countries we are at a
point you've alluded to it where
everybody's angry no a lot of anger and
a lot of it's justified by the way whom
you could talk about that you know
income inequality and all those things
so it's justified anger but it seems to
me that there are people of goodwill who
need to band together to diffuse the
anger in our societies otherwise we
won't have countries like the United
States yes the United States because
it's United and everybody
you've got the United flag there you
know said that there's a sense of
belonging identity and togetherness in a
country which you've got to preserve and
so I've stopped actually um picking I
Isis for example quite enjoy picking
fights with Deepak Chopra on Twitter
it's just for me to laugh
he says some crazy stuff in his hand but
I saw Thomas I've stopped doing it going
well but relative to some of the other
people right he's he's someone who means
well yes I don't agree with virtually
anything he says however he's a
well-meaning person yeah and so I've
started trying to seek common ground now
that's why I for example gave a talk to
the bishops they asked me to come you I
don't agree with them on the framework
their theological framework but they
mean well most of them yeah so I think
seeking consensus and diffusion anger as
you said is it is incumbent all of us
especially people like us you have a
public voice we need to defuse some of
this anger because otherwise it will
consume everyone yes I've tried very
hard to evolve in that respect and just
get better at communicating ideas and
get better at understanding how people
receive those ideas and I think that's
it's there's it's easy to get lazy and
to insult and especially me I mean I'm a
comedian what I do people yeah for humor
I want to entertain people that's the
whole idea behind it but I think in
terms of like discussing ideas
especially that are so personal to
people like religion I've I've
reexamined the way I interpret these
ideas and the way I talk about these
things
yeah there's a it's interesting there's
a I did a BBC program my age that I was
asked to do it on the thing call the
wreath lectures the babies that the BBC
have done since 1952 I think he was and
Robert Oppenheimer did them in 53 and it
was it's fascinating you can get the
transcripts online they're free and you
can get one recording of the five they
taped over the other four and you
believe it they raised them they wanted
to tape something but one of them
existed often Jaime giving these
lectures oh my god but you can read
better and Russell didn't do the Reaver
they taped over them Bertrand Russell
because tape was so expensive but he
talks of raising yeah but it's brilliant
it's cause science in the common
understanding and they weren't very
well-received because he thought he was
gonna talk about their Manhattan
projects so they thought he was gonna
talk about the atom bomb meaning is that
he was she ran it basically but he
didn't he talked about how its thinking
like a scientist which means thinking in
the way that nature forces you to think
can be valuable in other areas and it's
a that's an insight in itself the great
thing the unique thing about science is
nature forces you to think like that you
can't have an opinion can I have an
opinion about gravity just be gentle as
a building you can hit the ground that's
it doesn't matter what your opinion is
and and he said so if you think about
for example quantum mechanics so
sometimes you think of as particle like
an electron sometimes it has to it's a
point like object may behave like a
little billiard ball thing pool ball
that bounces around but sometimes it
behaves like an extended thing like a
wavy thing and nature forces you to hold
both ideas in your head at the same time
you know there's a get a complete
picture of the objects they're a
description of an electron and he said
that's the valuable thing about quantum
mechanics you know unless you're doing
electronics or inventing lasers you
don't need to know this stuff but if you
want to learn how to think you it's
valuable to be forced to hold different
ideas in your head at the same time mmm
it's really teaching you not to be an
absolutist straight teaching you the
example he uses is because he was I
think he was had problems with McCarthy
and all those things didn't he so you
think he's writing in the 50s so he said
you can either be you could be a
communist which in his definition would
be that you think the needs of the many
outweigh the needs of the few right so
so societies all that matters
oh it could be a libertarian all right
on the far conservative end where you
think that the individual is the only
thing that matters and that's it but
actually of course to have a function in
society you need a mixture of the two
and we can wait it one way or the other
but you need to hold both ideas in your
head at the same time and that's he said
that one of the most valuable things
about science because it forces you into
modes
thought they're valuable and that's what
we're talking about here it's so
absolute physicians are always a just a
blinkered sort of subset of what's
actually happening you can't understand
the world by being an extremist yeah
you've got to hold all these views in
your head well that I find that so often
on this podcast because I talk with
people I agree with end disagree with
and I always try to put myself in the
head of the person that I disagree with
I always try to figure out how they're
coming to those conclusions or where
they're coming from yeah and I think
it's so it's so important to not be
married to ideas I got a conversation
with someone about this and they said
like sometimes you change your opinions
a lot I go yeah I do flip-flopping I'm
not a politician like I'm not
flip-flopping I'm thinking yeah I'm not
sure I'm not sure like I I will have one
opinion on a thing whether it's a
controversial thing like universal basic
income I'll change my mind a hundred
percent in two weeks
yeah now I think it's probably a good
idea yeah and then I'll go back and
forth no no no no no people need but
it's as cruel as it seems they need
motivation they need and I don't know I
bounce around with these things yeah but
I've tried really hard as I've gotten
older to have less absolute opinions
yeah yeah Richard Fineman another great
physicist wrote a similar essay a
similar time to Oppenheimer and he also
works in the Manhattan Project it's
called the value of science and I think
that was 1955 and they both shared
actually a surprise I think that they
were still alive because they thought
that the power they'd given to the
politicians the atom bomb would destroy
everything they didn't think that a
political system would control it and it
did so that's an emotion remarkable
thing yeah we're still here but in in in
that essay he said the the most valuable
thing about science is the realization
that we don't know and he said he said
in that statement he calls science is
satisfactory philosophy of ignorance by
the way he said in that statement is the
open door the open channel he called it
if we want to make progress we have to
understand that we don't know everything
and we have to leave things to future
generations and we can be uncertain and
we can change our minds and he said that
that's that it's a great last line I
come exactly what he says but he said
it's something like is our duty as
scientists to communicate the value of
uncertainty and the value of freedom of
thoughts to all future generations
that's the point that's what freedom of
thought means freedom of thought means
the freedom to change your mind in fact
said that's what democracy is if you
think about it democracy is a trial and
error system so it's the it's the
admission that we don't know how to do
it therefore we'll change every four
years we'll change the president or
every eight years we'll change the
president why because the president
doesn't know how to do it so that
someone better they will do someone
better that comes along and then someone
worse and someone better but it's a
trial and error system and he's right
and he's right that that is the open
door that's that that's the road to
progress he's certainly better than
humility yeah one of the things that I
love so much about Bertrand Russell and
about Fineman was how human they were
they were very human I mean finally like
to play the bongos and who's chasing
girls and Bertrand Russell was addicted
to tobacco he would talk about how he
wouldn't fly unless he could smoke like
he had to get us was back when they had
smoking sections on airplanes and he had
his pipe and he just refused to fly
without tobacco and he couldn't imagine
being without tobacco well yeah that's
so strange for such a brilliant guy to
be addicted to such a gross thing yeah
you're right because I think these these
are faithful that found existence joyous
yeah wanted to know they just wanted to
know stuff yeah didn't want to know
everything because you can't know
everything right yeah I suppose that's
what if you think about what the job of
the scientist is is to is to stand on
the edge of the known because you're a
research scientist so if there's nothing
to know then you've got no job so you
have to be naturally comfortable with
not knowing and if there's one thing I
really do think we was how do we begin
to patch our countries back up again one
of the reasons I think in education is
to teach people the value of on
certainty but not knowing it is not weak
right to not know it's actually natural
not to know and that's one of the
freedom is with religion is to say that
you know when you do not hard to say
that you have absolute truth and
absolute knowledge of something yeah
when it can't really exist yeah I mean
history tells us doesn't it that yeah
anyone who thinks they've got absolute
knowledge is a cause he's trouble yeah
did you see ex machina yeah did you
enjoy it yes yes I know him Alex Garland
because he wrote sunshine oh right 28
days later
yeah and yeah new movie the weird one
the alien movie he wrote that as well
right yes a great soundtrack yeah yeah
did you are you scared of artificial
life artificial intelligence and you
know I might scare the [ __ ] out of me
yeah when he talked about it like he
talks about it like were in the opening
scene of a science fiction movie where
he's trying to warn people and then they
don't listen to the genius and it goes
south so depends I chaired a debate on
this for the role sites in London a few
weeks ago and the so it's treating now
at the moment what people seem to be
frightened of a general a is no I AG I
they call artificial general
intelligence which is like what we
talked about earlier a human-like
capability thing yes and we miles away
from that we don't have to do it we
haven't got them and we're miles away so
at the moment artificial intelligence is
expert systems and very focused systems
that do particular things you can be
scared of them in a limited economic
sense because they're going to displace
people's jobs and actually interestingly
in this panel discussion we had it's
going to be like why you Mike on
middle-class jobs in the UK so
white-collar jobs it's not actually why
people are interested in universal basic
income to sort of replace money that's
kind of lost because there will be no
jobs for all these people otherwise we
have just a mass catastrophe yeah
they're very good someone said that
these systems are special intelligence
systems at the moment they're very good
at doing things like lot lawyers work so
they're very good at reading contracts
and things
that's interesting it's a revolution
it's not like the Industrial Revolution
where it's manual labor that gets hit
necessarily this is kind of interesting
because it hits that kind of
intermediate level that usually escapes
so you're right one of the answers is to
tax there was an example was a robot
tank so in a car factory you say to the
manufacturer well okay you can have a
robot well you pay the robot the same as
you pay a person and then that money
goes into funding universal basic income
or something like that
mhm so I think there's got to be an
economic change because these systems
will be there but all the experts I
suppose who agreed the the idea of a
Terminator style general intelligence
taken over the world is miles away and
so whilst we might start thinking about
the regulation it's not going to happen
soon is the general point I think so I
would disagree with him on that I think
I think it's too far in the future at
the moment I thought it might be one of
those people that's okay it's gonna be
all right right and then then you know
my iphone takes me out on the way so a
choice at the moment isn't it I mean
don't don't give your iPhone a laser
that doesn't matter if it goes crazy and
tries to take over the world I know I
know that's a bit facetious because they
can he would say they could take over
power grids and all that kind of stuff
yeah well it's these concepts that are
really hard to visualize like sir Kurt's
Wiles idea of the exponential increase
of technology leading to us to a point
in the near future where you're gonna be
able to download your consciousness into
a computer you talk to computer expert
still like there's no way we're miles
away from that yeah on you're a
scientist yeah scientist one brain cell
probably we can but Kurzweil is
convinced that what's gonna happen is
that as technology increases it can
increases in this wildly exponential way
where we really can't visualize it we
can't even imagine how much advancement
will take place over 50 years but in
those 50 years something's going to
happen that radically changes our idea
of what's possible and I think Elon
shares this idea as well that
gonna sneak up on us so quickly that
when it does go alive it'll be too late
yeah I mean it's worth putting the the
the framework in place
I think the regulatory framework even as
you said for the more realistic problem
which is people's jobs are going to get
displaced yes
and there's a great I was at a thing and
some someone said I come he was but they
said that the jury was a politician the
the job of the innovation system is to
create jobs faster than it destroys them
so you've always got to remember that as
a government and as regulators if you're
going to allow technologies into the
marketplace that destroy people's jobs
it is your responsibility to find a way
of replacing those jobs or compensating
those people as you said otherwise you
get breakdown so human being those that
people need some meaning like they just
giving them income I think is just gonna
mean just my speculation but it's gonna
create mass despair even if you provide
them you provide them with food and
shelter they need people need things to
do so it's there's going to be some sort
of a demand to find meaning for people
give them occupations give them
something some tasks let's say it seems
to be one of the critical parts of being
a person so we need things to do that we
find meaning in you know like you were
talking about we're the only things that
we know of that have meaning that find
meaning and share meaning and believe in
that we're gonna need something like
that if universal basic income comes
along I don't think it's going to be
enough to just feed people and house
them yeah they couldn't want something
to do if you know a person is a you're
doing something for an occupation and
this is your identity and then all
sudden that occupation becomes
irrelevant because computer does it
faster cheaper quicker these people are
gonna have this incredible feeling of
despair and just not being valuable yeah
I mean oh what wonder utopian so their
version of this is that everybody gets
to do what we're doing now Rush's make a
living so thinking and creating and now
that kind of you know so that that's the
the utopian ideal is you don't need to
do the stuff the job that you don't
really want to do in the factory
you can do the thing that humans are
best at that but I agree it's that's a
very utopian view yeah does everybody
want to do that or does everybody have
their mindset well because we're
education if everybody had an interest
like that if everybody went on to make
pottery and painting and doing all these
different things they've always really
wanted to do and their needs are met by
you know the universal basic income
money they receive every month but boy
there's a lot of people I don't think
have those desires or needs and to sort
of force them onto them at age 55 or
whatever it's gonna be yeah seems to be
very very difficult yeah yeah I agree
yeah it's a big challenge but I think
that in concept at least it's inevitable
that we do have some sort of an
artificial intelligence that resembles
us or that resembles something like ex
machina if people choose to create that
I mean choose to create it in our own
image but that's very godlike isn't it
God created us in his own image yeah and
again yeah see I don't know that when I
talk to people in the field as you
probably have most of them say don't
have to do it yes it's really right it's
gonna be miles away so maybe I'm hiding
my head in the sand a bit but I don't
think so I think it's I think we'll know
it when I don't think anyone's gonna do
it accidentally right so I I don't think
it's just suddenly going to be upon us I
I think we will see we'll see ourselves
getting acquiring that capability we'll
see ourselves getting close we'll see
their systems beginning to emerge in
them we'll think about it just think 200
years ago if you wanted a photograph of
something you want to picture something
you had a draw it I mean there was no
photography 200 years ago yeah I mean
just think of that it's almost
inconceivable no automobiles no
photography what was automobile about
maybe there was some sort of machines
that drove people around right something
close there wasn't three is earlier than
that
right you go back 500 years you have
almost nothing yeah it's crazy how we've
been quick it's so fast
it's so fast I mean and then this what
we're doing right now that there's
people right now in their car that are
streaming this so they're in their car
and they're listening as they're driving
on the road maybe they have a Tesla
maybe they have an electric car they're
driving down the road streaming to
people talking where it's ones and zeros
that are broken down and there's some
audible form and you can listen to it in
your car that is bananas yeah I agree
we've been quick so quick well think of
the world you know the internet I mean
it's a it said not long I mean I
remember it being invented yeah you know
oh well certainly the web went on so the
web well it was very early for me
because I was in doing particle physics
and of course that the web comes from
CERN the WWE bit right so it's certainly
in the early 90s I was involved in that
you know in the university environment
with email and all that kind of stuff
so I don't know when it kind of didn't
really you could you could have a web
browser that just the only sites they
were there in NASA and I think NASA had
one of the early sites and CERN it was
very little oh when did you become
involved with CERN so that would be I
started doing particle physics in 95 and
when was when did the Large Hadron
Collider go alive that was an I remember
2000 and 2007 I think he pause of 2008
is so long ago about 10 years ago but he
started that we stayed up and then we
had a problem with it and then it took a
bit a while to fix it hasn't been taking
data that long but it's a tremendously
successful thing now and its operating
beyond its design capabilities it's
quite incredible it's so stunning a
physical thing that this how large is it
how long is in its 27 kilometres so I
sat about 60 miles 16 miles and it's a
circular yeah sort of a building yeah
well I say it's a big cube I mean you
think basically is mainly under France
and partly under Switzerland and it
accelerates protons
around in a circle both ways they won't
one beam goes well my one goes the other
way and they go around 11,000 times a
second because that's so very close to
speed of light 99.999999% the speed of
light and then we cross the beams and
collide the particles and in those
collisions you're recreating the
conditions that were present less than a
billionth of a second after the Big Bang
so we know that physics so going back we
said about the carbon and the oxygen we
can trace that story back way beyond the
time when they were protons and neutrons
so when there were quarks and gluons
around and and go all the way back and
the Higgs boson doing its thing back
then and we so we can see all that
physics in the lab so that's why we have
some a lot of confidence in that story
it's so fascinating that they were able
to talk someone into funding that that
they got a bunch of people together and
that you you were able to explain to you
know politicians and and you know
regular people what what you're trying
to do it's a great example of how you
get something done so it was the night
the fifties when certain was established
I think was 53 or 54 can't quite
remember it something like that and then
it was built out from the Second World
War so you have Europe at the end of the
war and it was realized that the only
way forward for you it was collaboration
to rebuild the scientific base and in it
for peace for peaceful purposes and so
CERN was set up as an international
collaboration in Europe initially with
that political ideal that it was it was
explore nature just for the freely and
for peace for peaceful means and
peaceful reasons and and so that was a
the pilet the politics was right so it
was said it by international treaty so
that the member states are bound
together by treaty and they pay a small
amount relatively small amount each into
CERN every year which is a percentage of
their GDP and that's the money they used
to build do the experiments and build
the accelerators so it's very hard to
get out of it and you wouldn't really
want
because it's a small amount of money per
country and CERN doesn't extra money to
build things
it just takes its money and basically
saves up and plans itself but because
it's got a regular stream of money it
can do it so you can say we're gonna
build this machine and it will take 8
years because that's how much money
we've got and we'll build it in 8 years
and we know how much money we've got so
we can do it you know it's a lesson I
mean that the reason that the u.s.
Collider the SSC failed is because it's
the problem you have in the US with the
funding system as you've seen in the
last few weeks yeah is that it's very
arbitrary and it's open to political
maneuvering and things can be shut down
and take and uncertain is not like that
CERN has got a guaranteed stream of
funding small from each country and so
you can do these projects and the one in
the u.s. that was during the Clinton
administration so what it was yeah it
was close
was it Clinton it was closed down by
Congress and a very slim vote and it was
in Texas so it was it was one of those
things where you got States vying for
money and he was half built mm-hmm and
everyone was there you know I mean the
thing it was bigger than the LHC it was
so you waste a lot of money is that a
huge disappointment for a scientific
community like where people very hopeful
that this was going to go along yeah it
was being built dug half the tunnel what
would it be able to do that the LHC
couldn't it was a higher energy
accelerator than the LHC so it would
have discovered the Higgs particle first
had it been running but the the half
bill part is it useless now or can they
I think you know so that's the thing it
you can do these wonderful things for
not a lot of money if you just do it
over many years and have stable funding
yeah it's commit to doing it the filling
in in part asleep and you look at CERN
as well and people you have people ask
me now I think the UK pays about it's
about one hundred million dollars a year
that's what the UK pays in and it's
about same for Germany same for friends
and so on and so people say what do we
get for that I mean first of all it's
not the whole budget of CERN is about
the same as a budget of a medium-sized
university
so it's not a lot it's about a billion
dollars a year or something which is
what a university has so it's not a lot
in the scheme of things what's it done
though
well we invented the world wide web as
we've just said a lot of the medical
imaging technology they were use comes
from CERN it's pioneered the use of
these very high field magnets which is
what it needed
so it's engineering at the edge and
engineering at the edge generates
spin-offs and expertise to get used in
other fields so there's cancer treatment
so-called hadron beam therapy so if
you've got a brain tumor now it's quite
likely that you'll have one of these
targeted particle beam therapies which
is like very highly targeted sort of
chemotherapy it's not chemotherapy it's
radiation that you can target in the
beam into your head and attack the tumor
and those those are particle
accelerators so most particle
accelerators today are in hospitals and
in medicine but they came from doing
particle physics that so the the
spin-offs of these big experiments at
the edge of our capability are always
immense which is why they worth funding
at these very low levels but it's not
just the knowledge it's the engineering
expertise that there is a practical
application for every everyday
there always is it's just finding out
how to do hard things is usually useful
the model and it wasn't just the Higgs
boson particle that you guys are
discovered what is quark gluon plasma
yes that that's a shortly after the
billionth of a second after the Big Bang
yeah you end up with a soup of quarks
and gluons so quarks are the building
blocks of protons and neutrons and
gluons are the things that stick them
together and so a proton has two up
quarks and a down quark and in each one
has two down quarks and up quark and so
on so their constituents the protons and
neutrons which are the constituents of
our atomic nuclei so we go if you go to
very high temperatures our high energies
then the protons and neutrons fall to
bits then you end up with a soup of
quarks and gluons
then that's a quark gluon plasma and
it's insanely dense right
yeah well very high-energy so so you get
that so
we've been exploring that by could we
don't only collide protons together we
can collide lead nuclei together or
silver nuclei together at the LHC and
that's when you make these kind of soups
of nuclear matter if you like very hot
nuclear matter to explore that physics
to that and that nuclear physics Wow and
I was reading something about the the
weight of of that stuff that like a
sugar cube like what is that what is the
actual weight well it depends our
density is that so don't they're I mean
they were the thing I remember is it the
sugar cube of a neutron star material
which is I don't know how many hundred
million tons I can you know that it
depends but so I don't know with the
quark-gluon plasma I don't know what
number you there was something it was
one of the things after the discovery
they were talking about the massive
weight of quark gluon plasma and like
yeah almost incomprehensible yeah yeah I
don't know the number of it but
something crazy yeah yeah now one once
these you got something here does 40
billion oh my god a cubic centimeter
would weigh 40 billion tons oh yeah the
densest matter created in the Big Bang
machine what are they doing right now
it's a closed for engineering and
upgrades upgrades yeah I mean one thing
we're trying to do is one of the things
in particle physics is that you want as
many collisions per second as you can
generate and then they we have a
collision whether what's got a bunch
crossing LHC we can bury it but it's
something like 25 nanoseconds different
they don't want so it's really we get a
lot of collisions per second and and the
more collisions per second you can get
the more chance you have in making
interest in things like Higgs particles
or whatever else may be out there
waiting to be discovered that means it's
possible there are other particles out
there that we haven't yet discovered
that could be within the reach of the
LHC and if this one that was in Texas
had gotten built and it was more
powerful
then the LHC you'd have even more
opportunity to do something like that
yeah now when these things are created
by these collisions how long do they
last
oh fractions of a second so that the
general rule in physics in particle
physics is that they're the more massive
it is and the more things it can decay
into the faster it will do that so
basically the heavy things decay into
light things and so the only the stable
particles are things like electrons and
some of the quarks and the up quarks and
down quarks are stable things but so
everything tends to decay very fast so
we're talking fraction billionths of a
second fractions and how are they less
than that are they registering its
existence like what is uh what is being
used to measure it so what you see if
you collide what are they I see we
collide protons together then-president
got loads of stuff in them loads of
gluons and the quarks so you get a big
mess first of all so most of it's a load
of particles Asprey and I wish you're
not interested in but sometimes when you
when let's say a couple of the gluons
bangs together and they can make
something interesting like a top quark
or a Higgs particle what's a top quark
it's up quite a very heavy there's six
quarks it says up and down charm and
strange bottom and top from end strange
yeah so it so strange was literally in
there was it the fifties I we discovered
them someone said that's really strange
strange a new kind of particle and so
that yes we have six quarks and they're
in three families so the up and down or
warm family and then the Chairman
stranger another family in the top and
bottom of the third family and so we for
some reason so the only thing the only
particles we need to make up you and me
they're up quarks down quarks and
electrons but for some reason there are
two further copies of those which you're
identically every way except they're
heavier so there's the charm and the
strange quark and if they're in a heavy
electron called a muon and then there's
a the top and the bottom quark and
another heavy electron called the tail
and that's it
so that there's this weird pattern that
we don't understand so we don't seems
like
you only needed the first family to
build a universe right right but for
some reason there are two copies now
heavy ones decay into the lighter ones
is the point so when you make them
they're not around very long and just
answer your question what happens is
that when they decay they throw their
decay products out into our detector so
we take a photograph of the cascade of
particles that comes from these heavier
particles decaying and the trick is to
patch it all up to see to try and so
work out what everything came from Wow
now when they five find these unexpected
particles then what happens then there's
the study of them then there's then
everybody gets together and go okay what
the hell is that
yeah what is that what do we do so we
want to know with a Higgs particle we
know what it does which is it gives mass
to everything so it's fundamentally the
thing that gives mass to all the other
things in the universe at the most
fundamental level so so electrons for
example and the up and down quarks there
get their mass from their interaction
with the Higgs that's why they're
massive that's another reason we exist
you know we go right back we wouldn't
exist if there wasn't mass in the
universe and the Higgs is ultimately
responsible for that mass I keep saying
I keep caveat in it because then you get
other sorts of mass that generated but
but that the fundamental basic seed is
it were it's from its from the Higgs and
so what we want to know is we want to
know how that thing behaves and their
weight so we're study is so you want to
make a lot of them so you can take a lot
of pictures of it and study a lot and
see exactly how it does that and so
that's what we're doing that's what
we're engaged in at the moment we're
making high-precision measurements of
the way that particle behaves so we can
understand the laws of nature and that
daddy's the laws of nature
how are those particles behaving and
what are they doing but it is possible
that some new form of some new form of
particles something else could be
discovered yeah the way we know about
yet because we know almost no that there
are other particles out there in the
universe we almost know a thing called
matter yes so we look how into the
universe and we see that there's a lot
of stuff there that it's interacting
gravitationally but it's not interacting
strongly with the matter out of which we
are made and the stars are made so it's
almost certain that that's some form of
particle that fits beautifully and we
see lots of different observations the
way galaxies rotate and interact and
even that oldest lie in the universe the
so-called cosmic microwave background
radiation we see the signature of that
stuff in that light as well so we think
that there's some of the particle out
there and and to be honest we thought we
would have detected it I think at LHC we
have lots of theories called
supersymmetric theories that make
predictions for all sorts of different
particles that would interact weakly
with normal matter and I yeah I think
it's broadly seen as a surprise that we
haven't seen them at LHC so that just
may well mean that either their vote
they're a bit too massive so we need
more energy to make them and we just
haven't quite got enough well we're not
making enough of them often enough to
see them which is one of the reasons we
upgrade in the LHC so we also look for
them by the way directly so we have
experiments under mountains we bury them
under mountains so the cosmic rays from
space don't interfere with them and
we're looking for the rare occasions
when these dark matter particles bump
into the particles of matter in the
detector so it's so because ya D would
be these rooms full of them I mean the
galaxies swimming with matter as far as
we can tell but it interacts very weakly
with this matter so it doesn't bump into
us very often so we're looking for the
direct detection of it and we're looking
to make those particles LHC so it's
everywhere but it doesn't interact with
us very weakly
and so interacts through gravity and the
the the archetypal particle that's
everywhere that doesn't interact
strongly is a neutrino so we do know
about neutrinos we've detected those and
there there are something like sixty
billion per centimeter squared per
second passing through your head now
from the Sun so they get made in nuclear
reactions in the Sun but they go
straight through
and actually straight through the earth
pretty much
occasionally one of them bumps into
something and we can detect those
because with so many of them going
through but we only detect you know know
one or two a day and the idea is that
dark matter encompasses an enormous
percentage of the universe yes it's five
times as much matter is dark matter than
is normal matter and the number is
twenty five percent of the universe so
it's roughly speaking about five percent
of the universe is normal matter stars
in gas 20 say percent as dark matter yes
oh yeah five Norma about 25 dark matter
in about 70s dark energy that's the
other thing yeah yeah so what the hell's
that don't know know what it does so
again what see we got we talked about
Einstein's theory earlier so Einstein's
theory which works spectacularly well
says that if you put stuff into the
University we said before then it warps
and deforms and stretches and it very
precisely tells you given the stuff that
you put in it how much does it stretch
and how does it stretch and the the
measurement we have is how its
stretching so so we observe the thing we
observe is how the universe is expanding
and how that expansion rate is changing
and how it's a ship how it's changed
over time so we have very precise
measurements of that so then we can use
the theory to tell us what's in it given
that we know what how it's responding to
that stuff and that's how we discover
dark energy so we noticed that the
universe's expansion rate is increasing
so the universe is accelerating in its
expansion which is exactly the opposite
of what we thought noticed in the 1990s
that we discovered that so we can work
out what sort of stuff and how much of
that stuff you need to put in the
universe to make that happen and that's
where we get these numbers from was your
resistance to that when that was first
proposed yeah I remember my one of my
friends at Brian Schmidt got the Nobel
Prize for that and then I remember I
talked to him and he said he was a
postdoc I think at the time so young
and he made he's making measurements of
supernovae the light from supernova
explosions which is so bright that you
can see them you know hundreds and
millions billions of light years away
and he noticed that if you look at the
date so the light is stretched in the
wrong way so we look at the stretch of
light as it travels across the universe
and the universe is expanding it
stretches the lights so it changes the
color and he noticed that it was a
discrepancy which which said that the
universe that the expansion rate is
speeding up it's been speeding up for
him think something like seven billion
years or so it's been speeding up so he
thought these done something wrong
because it you know so so he checks it
and checked in checked it and he
couldn't find anything wrong so he did
what a good scientist does which is he
published it so that somebody else could
find out what he'd done wrong and he
said that he thought it would be the end
of his career he thought I'd be a
laughingstock you know then he got the
Nobel Prize because he was right it is
stretched Wow
it's a great lesson means that if you if
you're sure that you can't see what
you've done wrong then you publish it
because back to that thing about
humility we saw it earlier you know what
we ultimately we're not trying to be
right we're trying to find out stuff and
so the good scientists will be really
happy if they set out to be wrong
because they've learned something yeah
that's that it's good that yeah that's
that because he got the Nobel Prize now
when he received the Nobel Prize in this
concept started being discussed what was
the initial reaction to it well it's
it's interesting because it's allowed in
Einstein's theory and it was in
Einstein's original theory so it's
called it's got a name it's called the
cosmological constant and that's a it's
it just allowed in the equations and
Einstein actually introduced it
initially so because I signs the
equations strongly suggest that the
universe is expanding or contracting and
not just sat there so even before we'd
observed anything
Einstein had a theory that suggested
that the universe is just not static and
actually really strongly suggest that
there's a beginning right so that the
theory itself on its own suggests that
you can see that if the universe is
stretching today then
have been smaller in the past right
everything must've been closer together
let's say that so the as a man that
chuckles George Lemaitre who was a who
worked independently of Einstein but the
same time in the early 1920s before we
even knew there were other galaxies
beyond the Milky Way and they noticed
that the the equation suggests the
universe might be stretching and so he
wrote to Einstein and said your theory
suggests there was a day without a
yesterday because he thought if
everything's expanding now then he must
have been closer together in the past
and so there might be a time when it was
all together and he was a priest well so
it's a Belgian priest so I think I mean
I wrote about this now it's kind of mind
socialization of it but I think that he
was more predisposed to accept what the
equations were telling him because a
beginning an origin for a priest is
really a nice thing because it tells you
the creation event and Einstein tried to
dodge it and and put this allowed term
into his equation which is the almost
the stretchy term so say well if it's
all if it's all kind of contracting or
something can I put something in to make
it stretch a bit to balance it all out
so it can be eternal so an you can't you
can't make it eternal that way but he so
tried it then he took it out and called
it his biggest blunder taking it out was
ya know you can't put any in his biggest
blunder or at least some people think
what what he'd done was miss the
prediction of the Big Bang really so by
trying to fiddle around to have a static
universe that's stable
he missed what the equations were
screaming his own theory was screaming
to him which is that no the universe
expands or contracts and he missed it
right so I think that's probably what he
meant by biggest blunder but in any case
he took it out and then later in the
1990s it turns out there no it's there
but it's really small it's a tiny tiny
effect but it's still dominating the
universe now and it will and it will
dominate even more in the future so we
think that we're in the universe that
will continue to expand essentially
doubling in size
a fixed time scale which is about twenty
billion years so within every twenty
billion years into the future forever
unless something happens the universe
will continue to expand and double in
size two years and that's the dark
energy that's driving it but nobody
knows what it is it's the it's one of
the cutting edge massive problems in
theoretical physics and what is being
done to try to get a better grasp of
what it is
I mean it's theoretical at them I mean
we're making very precise observations
of it right but it looks like this
constant so it looks like it's basically
one number if you like in Einstein's
equations and just really simple so it
looks like it's something that's maybe a
property of space itself don't know but
it looks like a very simple thing that
doesn't change over time and just stays
there so so it requires theoretical
advance as well and so people are trying
very hard to do that it's so crazy when
you go from Galileo to modern
theoretical physics that they're still
in the myths of this understanding yeah
of what all this stuff is yeah I mean
that these are you know these are
fundamental and difficult problems and
we're talking about the origin and
evolution of the universe right that's
what cosmology is and it's also particle
physics I mean the way that these things
this stuff we keep talking like this
stuff in the universe that's what the
LHC studies it studies how the stuff
behaves um right now these are it's very
theoretical right they're trying to wrap
their their minds around what this is
and what the properties of it are do you
envision a time where you can actually
physically measure this and then have a
a real clear understanding of what it is
and what its properties dark energy and
I I don't know I mean for example there
are theories for example which you're
probably not right but they're not
necessarily wrong either there are
theories that try to link it to the
Higgs particle so the Higgs particle
which we've discovered and can measure
has some properties that we think the
dark energy would need
and also this inflation that I mentioned
way back at the start of the universe as
some of the prophecies that can do that
as well so for example there are
fearfully tries to link them so we do
have an observation of the Higgs we can
study that so are they linked don't know
and so it could be that we can study it
even though it's a very small weak
effect and it could be web direct access
food so it's great I mean it's just
these are big mysteries that there's
something really profound we don't
understand about the way that stuff in
particular the Higgs actually interacts
with space and time so very naively the
Higgs should blow the universe apart
just very naively it's loads of energy
in a very small amount of space huge
amounts of energy in the Higgs field but
it doesn't do anything apart from give
mass to things it doesn't seem to it
doesn't directly affect space but
everything else that you put in space
directly affects it so you know there
are there are kind of issues there that
we don't and it just says we don't get
it we don't know we don't get it yet
it's just I can eat another one of those
they'd probably late that I if I stood
guess I'd say there's some link there
you know there's something going on and
solving one of them might solve the
other to inflation Higgs dark energy
something how many people worldwide
would you estimate are trying to grasp
this and working on this the good
question I don't know I mean it's a it's
probably tens of thousands tens of
thousands if you can all the people who
work at CERN and the particle physicists
and the theoretical physicists there'd
be tens of thousands because it's it's
so important to for us to get an
understanding of what's going on but yet
so outside of the grasp of most people
including me
like I'm listening to you talk about
this and I'm like thank God it's people
like you think whatever thank the think
quarks there's people like you out there
that are doing this but it it's almost
like you're speaking another language
it's so strange to me was very new stuff
yes you know I mean even when I was at
school and so when I when I was at
university we hadn't discovered the top
quark and we we sorta knew it was there
we thought the Higgs might be there but
we had no idea whether it was you know
so so we're moving in my career we're
moving quite fast and yet you're right
these are the most fundamental questions
about what Weiser eat ultimately why is
the universe the way it is and even
possibly why is there a universe right
movie we're away from that yet but if
we're ever going to answer that it will
be by doing stuff like this and this is
all addressed in this live show that
you're doing this world yeah live show
and certainly be they also the
consequences of the not that comes words
of knowledge but the the cosmology is
terrifying that as we've started with so
I think it as we've said it raises
questions it makes quite vivid questions
that we all have about you know what are
what are we doing here right this sigh
try I think it's got all the way back to
me really been into Cal Sega and he
always used to try this you you try to
link it to things that people think
about naturally then that's why people
are fascinated by this stuff because
they do actually think about it you
might not be with the right names or the
right words or the right facts even but
they're thinking about how did I get
here how did I come to exist what is the
future do we have a future
what was our past yeah these these are
universal questions I think there
certainly are and the way you're doing
this with your live show you were saying
that you have an enormous visual aspect
to it well we have a we we have the
biggest screen we can get in every venue
and it's led it's when the the
state-of-the-art modern LED screen so
they're like Lego then you can build
them so you fill the venue with it so
you know Wembley Arena
then it's 30 meters wide whatever by 8
meters high it's enormous
you must have a huge crew carrying on
yeah 16 or 18 people and
to rock'n'roll show some of the venues
were doing in North America they're in
Canada they're a bit smaller venues but
we just fill it with screen as much as
we can get and then the graphics a lot
of the graphics I I have we're done by a
Dean egg who did ex machina actually
Aunt Estella and the reason I I mean I I
say chose them I drank them up and goes
please please will you do this and they
said how much money have you got and you
know cuz it's way lower than Chris Nolan
yeah they did it they were mean that
they just liked the idea of these
messages and these ideas so they use the
software that they use for interstellar
to create images of black holes Wow and
they they use general relativity they
coded it into their their graphics
software so they can rate race lights
around black holes and you can move the
camera around the black hole and it
traces the way all the light moves
around it so if you remember those
amazing get the gargantuan the black
hole in interstellar that's that's a
simulation it's not an artist's
impression it's a simulation of what
Einstein's theory tells as a black hole
will look like and so I can use that to
talk about what happens when you fall
into a black hole what would you see
watching someone fall in and you can
explain all that using Einstein's theory
you know the idea that it's kind of a
well-known idea it's a bizarre idea that
if I was to fall into a black hole and
you were watching you'd never see me
falling you'd see time slowed down my
time slowed down as you watch me so in
the end I'd just slow down and slow down
and slow down and then I get frozen on
the event horizon and just fade away as
an image a reddening image on the event
horizon so time passes at different
rates as you move close to the black
hole and far away because space and time
have distorted by the mass of the black
hole and so I could I talk about all
that but I talk about all that with this
incredible image which we had it's so
high resolution by the way that they it
was higher resolution than they're used
for interstellar because my screen so
big so so we need a special machine to
play it you can buy the most expensive
Mac Pro in the world and it will not
play this stuff so I loved that from a
geek perspective
you have a special video player to play
the dampers just like a series of CPUs
are attached together and some sort of a
super yeah it's yeah it's one of those
this one's a big sort of visualization
graphics things but but these files are
like you know there are 20 gig video
files Wow because there's so many pixels
might the Pixar resoluteness is really
geeky in it fakes the resolution 6400 by
1536 so impress my screen
it's a lot like that yeah are you coming
to Los Angeles with this yeah wait a
month Taliban Theatre in May the end of
me I'm there yeah I'm here
oh yeah no you've gotta come 24th of May
oh you're in San Diego as well
hey I gotta see one of these yeah it's
gonna be great fun and however much
stuff we can fit into those handsome
devil look at that nice jacket on
looking good someone gave me that to
scrounge that but it's cool cuz you're
looking a cool guy cool guy with space
behind you that's awesome man well
listen thank you so much for doing this
I really appreciate you appreciate
everything you're doing it's awesome
no thank you I always enjoy crying I
loved it last time and people still talk
about it when I was on less time more
people ask me about making you than but
should anybody else say get ready like
because it's like a hundred times more
popular than it was back then is it it's
gonna be very strange now but thank you
again really appreciate it I can't wait
to see your show thank you so much thank
you
[Music]